e
e e
so the members will notice that uh we
have an amendment today that was passed
out when we get to
FNA um so I draw that to your attention
before we get to that and
um we're going to just so that everybody
knows before we actually call the dam
Bill
629 for a vote we're going to take a
break uh everyone has agreed the
leadership has agreed we're going to
have a caucus break uh because of an
amendment that was submitted and some
other issues that have risen regarding
the dam Bill very important bill so
there'll be a short break maybe five
minutes uh 10 minutes uh before we get
to 6:29 then we'll reconvene and go back
to to 629 and the rest of the bills and
we will have a caucus after uh in the
afternoon after we hear 691 FN for the
three bills this afternoon and the last
I looked on the website will this will
complete our 21
bills so and we may I'm told by the
speaker we might get some bills coming
over early from the Senate that may come
to us but as of right now we should be
all set until March after today and
again remember
um now we're going to have to write
reports for all these so again those
that are writing the reports will be the
maker of the motion and all the Democrat
motions and makers that you send your
report to representative NAB and the
Republicans send them to me then I
accumulate them together I send them off
to our staff and then it gets placed on
the calendar you have to watch the
calendar because there'll be a lot of
bills coming in and I'm told we're going
to have session probably three four
times before we get to March uh except
for that February vacation so I don't
know when the bills were exacting today
will be on they could be on the
following week they could be on two
weeks they could be three weeks so you
you just have to read and read the the
uh calendar uh so then you'll know when
we'll be up on the floor uh we have a
number of bills on the floor tomorrow so
I'm hoping everybody can be here for
that appreciate it uh so now I'm going
to call the hearing on HB
568 allowing subdivision regulations
concerning water supply the exec on this
and I believe uh representative donelly
you have a motion thank you Mr chair I'd
like to make a motion of itl for
568 so we have a motion and do we have a
second second Mr
chair representative Bridal seconded the
maker would you like to speak to your
motion thank you Mr chair um so we heard
uh lots of testimony for House Bill uh
568 and some of the key notes that were
taken um is how this particular Bill uh
would really incur quite a bit of cost
uh for doing studies that can be
extremely costly and uh the towns
themselves have uh the you know the
jurisdiction over you know some of the
studies need to be done so we don't need
this overreaching bill in addition Dees
uh indicated that this was not a WID
widespread issue um so Wells that will
be drilled and and people will have you
know issues they will definitely be able
to work with the towns and work with the
community um to help you know identify
this and this should be very specific to
each community and how they need to do
this and not have a widespread um Bill
like this thank you does the second wish
to speak not at this time sir thank you
any other members wish to speak on
568 seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
read the
role HB 568 itl representative Davis yes
representative Gould yes representative
Donnelly yes clerk vote Yes
representative brial yes representative
Moffett yes representative Lenny yes
representative Taylor yes representative
NAB no representative Vale no
representative
Baldwin representative Darby no
representative Ryan no representative
buo representative Sergeant
no 97 chair and the
chair
yes didn't change the vote 97
thank
you moving on I open the executive
session on HB
582 relative to safety requirements for
operation of personal watercraft and I
believe representative Bridal has a
motion yes uh thank you Mr chair I move
to itl this bill and do I have a second
second so we have a motion made and
seconded representative would you like
to speak to your motion uh yes Mr chair
we currently in this state have
definition that um applies to personal
watercraft to further Define it is we
heard testimony that was uh Superfluous
and in addition to the language and uh
action that we took on the um personal
flotation bills uh last week um we
believe that this this
legislation um is unnecessary uh and so
that's why I moved to itl thank you does
second wish to
speak nope I think uh did quite a a good
job thank you thank you anyone else wish
to speak on HB
582 representative Derby thank you Mr
thank you Mr chair um this bill is a
safety Bill only um it applies Common
Sense uh safety measures that are
already in place for um uh ski craft
which um which are or the smaller
version of these personal
watercraft it
um uh as I as was discussed during the
hearing um if there were concerns
about um about uh personal
responsibility um you know they it would
be easy to amend this bill to remove the
requirement for wearing a life
jacket um just uh a couple of comments
on some of the testimony that was
received um during the hearing that um
being the um sponsor of the bill I
couldn't comment on one was that um
there was a comment that um there was
already uh language in place for um
careless and Reckless um uh that was
passed last year for careless and
Reckless watercraft Behavior while
that's true the bill last year actually
reduced um the uh that penalty from a um
misdemeanor to a um uh to a violation
this um uh puts in place um makes it a
viol uh misdemeanor again as is with ski
craft and there's also a comment about
there's no place to store um uh um pfcs
on a ski Craft on a jet ski all um
three-person ski crafts or a large
number of large person ski crafts have
actually storage compartments so that's
inaccurate as well so um all in all um I
I I believe that um New Hampshire should
take um uh
should take safety precautions for um
especially for uh you know younger
members of uh of our um of our
population and our visitors and uh
that's what this bill would have done so
I urge the uh the committee to oppose
the itl thank you anyone else wish to
speak
you seeing no one else uh will'll call
for a role
on
582 HB 582 I representative Davis yes
representative G yes representative
Donnelly yes clerk votes yes
representative Bridle yes representative
Moffett yes representative Lenny yes
representative Taylor yes representative
NAB
no representative Vale no representative
Baldwin no representative Derby no
representative Ryan no representative
buo representative Sergeant no and the
chair
yes
97 thank
you we on exec session on HB
595 595 relative to Coastal resilience
zones um I have a new maker
representative NAB do you have a motion
thank you Mr chair I motion we retain
this bill and I see the second Mr
representative Bridal the second anyone
else wish uh does the maker wish to
speak sure um you know I think this is a
really important bill that addresses a
huge issue in the state with flooding
both in coastal regions and in state and
um but we heard in in testimony it's a
really complicated issue the bill has a
lot of pieces so we think it needss a
little bit more work and a little more
time for the committee to tease apart
the different pieces and make it a good
bill so thank you Mr the second wish to
speak uh just to Echo representative
nab's comments this is a very um very
big bill with some good language in it
and it just I think it needs a little
more poish a little more time so thank
you anyone else wish to speak on
595 seeing none clerk will call the
role HB 595 to retain the bill
representative Davis yes representative
G representative Donnelly yes clerk
wrote yes representative
Bridal
hi representative Muffet
hi representa Lenny yes representative
Taylor yes representative NAB yes
representative Veil yes representative
Baldwin yes representative Derby yes
representative Ryan Yes representative
buo representative Sergeant yes and the
chair yes
160 and and for the record I'd like to
welcome uh representative Moffett who's
filling in today for representative
Dupont who was not able to be here
welcome to
resources it doesn't go any question was
asked the chair what happens if we
retain it it doesn't go anywhere I
report it's retained you won't see it on
the calendar it's just ret retain and
we'll deal with it with the other retain
bill that we already have and maybe more
um after the summer and then we have to
report it for our freshman then we have
to report it to the general court and it
will be on the calendar in January for
whatever we decide we're going to do
with
it okay thank
you exec session on HB 607 relative to
funding the Hampton Beach area
commission and making Appropriations
therefore I have a motion from
representative Bridal yes thank you Mr
chair I motion uh ought to pass and I
have a new second representative
Vale I second thank you do the maker
wish to
speak yes thank you Mr chair um this
policy recognized that the Hampton Beach
and the area commission that was um
created via Statute in 2003 um really
helps identify Hampton Beach uh as an
economic driver for this state and I
think um passing the funding of this
bill is good policy and um one of the
concerns that was brought up was the
financial issue and I know there's a
financial component to this and we we
wanted to pass that on to them but as
far as the policy goes we think this is
good policy so thank you Mr chair thank
you the second wish to
speak U my colleague has done a good job
of covering my remarks thank you thank
you any other comments on this bill
representative Darby thank you Mr chair
um I agree um that Hampton Beach is
important for the state it's also
important for Hampton Beach including
the um uh the businesses of Hampton
Beach um I don't believe that the state
should bear the entire cost of
um the
maintaining funds uh to run this
commission um I think it's while I think
it's fair for the state to provide some
there are already um there's already a
statute in place that allows the
commission to receive gifts um and other
um other funds to support themselves so
I um I won't be supporting this um as
written um I think that there should be
some um some recognition that other
funds need to be um coming from local
sources as
well anyone else wish to comment on this
bill
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to read
the role HB 607 ought to pass
representative Davis yes representative
G representative Donnelly yes clerk vote
Yes representative rdle yes
representative Moffet yes representative
Lenny yes representative Taylor yes
representative NAB yes representative
Vale yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby no representative
Ryan Yes representative buo yes
representative sergeant
yes 151 and shair
yes uh
151 if I can put this on consent do you
have a problem with it
okay I think they'll do that and then it
after consent if it passes it'll go to
finance moving
on open the exact session on HBC 624
establishing right the right one yeah
establishing a local River Management
advisory committee grant program and
making in Appropriations
therefore believe I have a motion from
representative Donnelly thank you Mr
chair I'd like to make a motion of ought
to pass and I have a second
representative Davis yes and I believe I
have a subsequent motion representative
NAB thank thank you Mr chair I would
like to move Amendment
68h do I have a second on that yes
representative Ryan seconds the motion
to amend and to adopt
68h speaking on the amendment
representative na thank you Mr chair um
this amendment if you look at lines 9
through 12 addresses an issue raised by
Dees that um moves moves it out of Ru
making and into a decision by the
Department of Environmental Services
given the small amount of money um it
felt like a more streamline process so
they are enabled to disperse the funding
with demonstrated need to implement the
duties described in RSA
48383 on a first come first serve basis
thank you thank you does the second wish
to speak representative
Ryan thank you anyone else wish to speak
on the amendment representative Darby
any other discussion on the
amendment seeing No Hands we're going to
vote on the amendment and after that if
it passes we'll vote on otpa so on the
amendment I'll ask the clerk to read the
role all right we are voting on
Amendment
20253 68h
representative Davis yes representative
Gould yes representative Donnelly yes
clerk votes yes representative rdle yes
representative Moffett yes
representative Loney yes representative
Taylor yes representative NAB yes
representative veale yes representative
Baldwin yes representative Derby yes
representative Ryan Yes representative
buo yes representative Sergeant yes and
the chair yes
160 the amendment passes 16 to0
so now we'll entertain another motion
from representative
naad um I most motion ought to pass as
amended for 624
FNA representative
Ryan second that I second that thank you
so we have a motion made and seconded
otpa on 624 any other
discussion thank you Mr chair I
definitely um support uh funding local r
Lo the local River Management advisory
groups um I think that um this bill
should have um provided an option to
receive funds from other sources
including um uh gifts um and any uh any
sources that come from that can be um
that can come from federal grants and
things like that um I'm going to vote
for it but I do um wonder if uh we
should consider
consider fixing this in the future to
allow for a wider uh input of funding so
the state doesn't have to keep paying
thank
you any other discussions on the motion
otpa seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
read the
roles HB 624 ought to pass as amended
representative Davis yes representative
gold yes representative Donnelly yes
clerk quotes yes representative Bridle
yes representative Moffett yes
representative leny yes representative
Taylor representative NAB yes
representative Vil yes representative
Baldwin yes representative Derby yes
representative Ryan Yes represent buo
representative Sergeant yes and the
chair
yes
consent consent
I'm now going to uh temporarily adjourn
the uh executive session on the rest of
the bills for this morning for five
minutes we're going to have a caucus
both uh Republicans and Democrats uh a
caucus and we'll be back in about five
minutes it shouldn't be a long caucus so
I have to ask those in the rear could
you please exit for five minutes and
we'll see you back here thank you a
short adjournment
be on consent but then it just gets
submitted to I thought you couldn't but
I see they do that they put it on
consent and then they
ship
e
e e
we're waiting for everyone to return
and I take us out of recess and as soon
as everyone's here we're going to take
up HB
629 oh
who's the new guy I didn't introduce
him um
don't no we'll keep we're retaining it
so we'll I've been I've been calling
he's here yeah oh cuz he's never
here okay
officially I call
the meeting back to order on executing
and we're starting with HB
629 I appreciate everyone giving us the
opportunity to recess for that short
period of time um representative Taylor
do I have a motion on HB 629 which
is funding the operation maintenance and
repair of State
dams thank you Mr chairman I move that
the bill be retained
thank you representative Bridal second
so we have a motion made and seconded do
you wish to speak to your motion
representative
Taylor thank you Mr
chairman the dams in this state uh do
need attention we all agree upon but how
we go about this is really being worked
out and as recently to as today we
received suggested amendments to this so
we need more time to work on this
therefore we're going
to U recommending this to be retained
thank you thank you does the second wish
to
speak no sir thank you thank you anyone
else wish to speak on the motion to
retain seeing none I'll ask the clerk
yes representative
Derby I need a little light
here you notice I was looking the other
way represent I did notice that thank
you very much Mr chair um I just want to
um acknowledge and appre appreciate the
work that the prime sponsor did um
putting together an amendment and I hope
that we can discuss uh his the contents
of his Amendment if we're going to have
a work session um on this retained bill
in the future thank you anyone
else sing n the clerk will read the role
HB 629 to retain representative Davis
yes representative Gould yes
representative Donnelly yes clerk votes
yes representative rdle yes
representative mfet yes representative
Lenny yes representative Taylor
representative NAB yes representative
Vil yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
Ryan Yes representative buo yes
representative Sergeant yes and the
chair yes
160 so I'll report that as being
retained that's our third retained
Bill moving on exact session on HB
644 relative to flying drones in state
parks I believe representative Darby you
have a motion yes thank you Mr chair I'd
like to make a motion um as inexpedient
to legislate on HB 644 thank you
representative
Donnelly second so have a motion Maiden
seconded to itl 644 representative Darby
wish to speak on your motion yes thank
you Mr chair um during testimony we
heard that um Department of parks and
rack is currently going through Ru
making um to see if there are
compromises for um for allowing um uas
use in you know remote areas of um parks
and ways to um to not uh conflict with
the recreational values of state parks
um so um this bill is uh is not
necessary because there's already a
process in place to hand that thank you
thank you the second wish to speak I
think representative Derby did a great
job thank
you anyone else wish to speak on
644 seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
read the roles HB 644 itl representative
Davis yes representative G
representative Donnelly yes clerk vot
yes representative rdle yes
representative Moffett yes
representative Lenny yes representative
Taylor yes representative NAB yes
representative Vale yes representative
Baldwin yes representative Derby yes
representative Ryan Yes representative
Buco yes representative Sergeant yes and
the chair yes
consent
consent and our last bill for this
morning executing HB
657 relative to short notice booking Act
access for New Hampshire residents to
state parks representative Davis you
have a
motion yes thank you um I move to
itl thank you representative
ghoul so have a motion maid and seconded
representative Davis speak to your
motion yes I'll make this short and
sweet the prime sponsor had asked us if
we would itl this bill and so that's my
motion second wish to speak no anybody
else wish to speak speak on this seeing
none I'll ask the clerk to read the
role HB 657 itl representative Davis yes
representative G yes representative
Donnelly yes clerk vote Yes
representative Bridal yes representative
Moffett yes representative Loney yes
representative Taylor representative NAB
yes representative Veil yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
Ryan Yes representative buo yes
representative Sergeant yes and the
chair yes
consent
good so that concludes our exacting
these bills this morning our next
hearing and it's a hearing will be at
11:30 on HB 663 allowing the division of
historic resources to expend moose plate
funds to administer in fund grants 11:30
so we'll adjourn till 11:30 thank you
very very much we'll see you
then
e
e e
helps if I turn on the mic good morning
welcome back to resources Recreation and
development I call the hearing to order
on HB 663 allowing the division of
historic resources to expend moose plate
funds to administer and fund Grant have
the prime SP
going to present the
bill um good morning Mr chair and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Karen Eble I represent um
marac district 7 which is New London and
Newbury um and I'm here to introduce
House Bill
663 um just to be clear I'm introducing
the bill at the request of the division
of historic resources so it's an agency
request um and the director of um Human
Resources Benjamin Wilson is here with
me today so if we need more details on
the bill um I think he'll be able to to
fill us in so basically um the the
division of historic resources along
with several other groups have Grant
programs that they utilize moose plate
money for and in this case we were just
talking over here historical resources
has a grant program that has been in
existence for 25 years so there's really
nothing new in in this bill the language
that you have in the bill that's in bold
is clarifying language to show that um
historic
sources in addition to purely using
moose plate money say to replace
shingles on a historic building can also
be used for the administration of the of
the program and obviously funding of the
grants so it's clarifying language um
and as he can tell you more about this
uh is confirmed by the attorney general
that this is an appropriate reading of
the statute as it stands now but it's
helpful uh for historic resources to um
have that confirmed in statutory
language so that's that's the upshot of
the bill I will say that I uh personally
as a member of finance division one that
res reviews dncr budgets and and men and
the budgets of many other agencies were
really really sensitive to the
diminished Revenue situ ation that they
all find themselves in and um I
certainly support anything that any of
those agencies can do to clarify in
statute um uh language that permits them
to use the full breath of the
opportunity provided to them by the
Moose plate money and anything else they
can get so um I'm also a member of the
of the elip board I'm not here in that
capacity either but um you know these
agencies really appreciate and depend on
moose plate money so with that um if you
have any questions I'll conclude my any
questions for the
representative representative
Taylor thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking the question was there any
consideration to make the monies also
available for state Register of
historical
sites
um well I'm going to ask ask uh do you
do you use it for State sites no there's
no there's been no discussion about that
I mean just representative just to
follow up on it this is a very
longstanding statute that's um you know
if we uh mess with it too much I think
it's going to be very complicating but
you know certainly anyway yep anyone
else seeing none thank you appreciate it
Mr Wilson division of historical
resources I'm handing out a packet that
has uh some information
that
there's I apologize
um and um there's the Attorney General's
uh opinion um which was sent uh via
email um there's also a report uh for
the last 25 years of actually 24 years
last fiscal year of uh moose plate um
Revenue
um Mr chair um committee members um I'm
Ben
Wilson I'm the director of the division
of historical resources uh DHR and uh
the state historic preservation officer
Department of Natural and cultural
resources uh thank you for this
opportunity to speak to House Bill
663 this proposed language addition to
the New Hampshire Conservation and
Heritage license plate program commonly
referred to as the Moose plate program
RSA 261 colon 97-
c1a was the result of asking the
Attorney General's office if DHR could
legally use a portion of its annual
moose plate appropriation to recover
administrative costs associated with the
program the answer was yes and I've
included as I mentioned that opinion uh
in your
packet we further asked uh if it would
be reasonable or helpful to add the
proposed language in HB 663 clarifying
and making the language more transparent
regarding the funds uh uses as they
apply to the DHR and again the answer
was
yes based on proposed budget cuts uh
alluded to Again by the representative
for the next banum we want to be certain
that we'll be able to operate our moose
plate grant program which may require
the DHR DHR using a portion of its
annual moose plate appropriation to
cover a portion of the program manager's
salary and benefits currently that
position uses Approximately 80% of its
time managing the moose PL grant program
which equates to
$11,932 of that position's current total
salary and
benefits um the DHR annually receives a
moose plate appropriation uh of between
$250 and
$300,000 uh which is then granted out to
municipalities for the restoration of
publicly owned buildings and other
historic
resources most individual grants are
between $10,000 and $20,000
and with that I'm happy to answer any
questions that you might have thank you
any questions representative NAB thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um the appropriation of the
$250 to
$300,000 that's what you get from the
state and then you get a this other
chart is the additional monies you get
so that's the total program thank you
for the question that's the total
program um amounts and uh the 250 to
300,000 is what is appropriated through
our department I apologize that have our
entire uh Department appropriation which
is larger um but depending on Department
U priorities um we receive an
appropriation of 250 to 300,000 my
followup thank you um so I just wanted
to clarify you're not using half of all
the Moose plate money toward this
position you also no the total program
is over looks like a million dollars a
year you get in revenues yes so yeah so
um yes then there are many agencies that
receive moose plate money as a whole
okay all right thank you any other
questions from Mr
Wills seeing none thank you for your
testimony could I just uh answer the
representative's question on uh hisor
register um so so the state Register we
consider that survey and that's that is
another program that the department uh
the division operates and it's in it's
in your handout uh the overview um
unfortunately we don't have
Appropriations for or specifically for
survey work for the state Register or um
or national register and I I wish we did
we've talked with our uh nonprofit um uh
agencies in the state like the
preservation Alliance New Hampshire
preservation Alliance to possibly create
a bank um where monies could be applied
for to then be able to do that survey
work um for state Register of national
register thank you
sure anything else same n thank you for
your
testimony is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on House Bill
663 representative Sergeant with the
blue sheets and the
online so online we have nine in favor
five opposed but two of those five
submitted attachments that relate to
other
bills uh so I think two of those opposed
are by mistake um one is for the
floration one is for uh the other Bill
we're considering and then here on the
blue sheet two in
favor blue sheet two in
favor and seeing no one else approaching
the mic I'm going to close the hearing
on House Bill
663 and we'll be back at 1:00 for House
Bill 683 FN relative to off Highway
recreational vehicles and then at 1:30
we have HB 691 FN prohibiting the
addition of floration chemicals to
Public Water Systems subsequent to that
we'll have both parties will have a
caucus and then we'll come back and
exect those three bills so thank you
very much and enjoy your lunch and we'll
see you after
lunch
e
e e
Mike good afternoon welcome to resources
Recreation and development I'm going to
open the hearing on HB 683 FN relative
to off Highway recreational vehicles as
you can see I have quite a few of these
pink cards with people that would like
to speak and we always love to hear from
everybody that wants to speak but I'd
just ask you if somebody before you or
the 10 people before you said the same
thing it would be helpful if you'd give
us your name and address and who do you
represent and how do you feel uh you
don't need to repeat what everybody else
said but I want you to be able to come
forward and let us know you're here and
how you feel I have one card in here
somebody wanted 10 minutes I would hope
that that was a slight exaggeration that
maybe they could take a little less that
would be nice but we don't want to cut
you off so I'm going to start with the
uh Prime sponsor representative Mike
wette C County
representative notified right across the
when 691
comes I don't
waste we can try to add ask uh
representative U sergeant if he can
remember to come get
you
representative uh good afternoon Mr
chair and committee members we're going
to kind of um do a tag team here I'm
going to talk about part of the bill and
uh Steve wiy from the uh Nova the
organization uh that represents the
aters in the state we'll talk about
part now just to make it clear what
we're talking about today is a process
we're not talking about opening roads
we're not talking about whether ATVs are
good whether they're bad this is a
process and this is a process that was
uh has been developed over the last 10
years and has worked very well in Coos
and grafting
counties as you know uh as we the uh
sport has grown you need trails and
sometimes to get to one section Trail to
another section Trail if you don't have
a Cooperative land owner you need a
piece of road to connect them uh and
it's either a Town Road could be class
six could be class five four and some
occasionally you need help from the
state of New Hampshire to connect to
Trails so what we found to be the right
process and keep everything transparent
was
the club will come to the town say we
need the Section Road to connect our
Trails they'll meet with a selectman the
selectman will look it over talk with
the public works department talk with
the police department and if they think
it can work the next thing they do is
notify all the abutters and schedule a
public
hearing then the public is notified
through newspaper ads online and uh
through um mail to all the butters and
then there's a public hearing then the
Selectmen make the decision whether they
want to open it or
not now when we add the part in there
for the
um state roads it's the same process it
goes from the club to the selectman
public
hearing butter is noticed then if
everything passes and the selectman are
happy then the do is approached and the
do uh using a Ros course is always a
final say so it's very transparent so
that everybody involved with the club
the town the abuts all know what's going
on everything's above
board and so when there's a problem the
town always has the ability to reverse
this decision at any
time uh the only way that um Trails work
are with Cooperative land owners so if
the town uh is seeing problems with law
enforcement or uh traffic or or problems
in the roads or deterioration they
always have the ability to cancel the
agreement and close it at any
time
um that's the way it has worked in Coos
and grafting County and and been very
successful and and again being very
transparent this part of the bill is
just expanding it to other counties so
that they have the ability and and this
process is in RSA so that it's just
adding it to other counties to be able
to have the same process if they want to
nobody says they have to nobody says
they they should shouldn't doesn't
matter but it it avails a process to
them if they'd like
to so again this really has nothing to
do with um whether you like ATVs or not
it's all about a process and a
transparent process and uh as far as uh
that goes that's um my my part of the
bill um Steve Wy from no will come up
and talk about the changing it from the
uh on the verified notification and how
that um works right
now do we have any questions for the
representative before he leaves his
seat I don't see none thank
you okay I didn't see any good thank you
very
much hi thank you uh for hearing us and
listening to this this bill we um over
the last seven years uh we do represent
all the ATV clubs in New Hampshire but
we also represent all the Riders um and
municipalities who have opened up their
roads to
ohvs um what has been very successful in
the North Country in connecting um large
riding areas um other towns across the
state have opened up their local roads
um to
ohvs
um I passed out this piece of paper
which has nothing but rsas outlining the
processes and the the laws where a
municipality can open this up and the
way the laws are written a municipality
can do this without a club and over the
last seven years I've gotten numerous
calls not just from a couple of clubs
that would like to connect some of their
riding areas but from residents and town
Selectmen on how to connect their riding
areas so we have places like cuden
Washington now I find Windsor from the
HB
113 um antrum who have opened up their
roads to ohvs but they have a state road
running right through the middle of town
often times these roads are 25 30 m an
hour uh short sections
1,500 half a mile 3/4 of Mile right in
town that they would like to connect one
side of their town to the other when
there isn't even a club there um ohrv
has become very popular people don't
just go up north to ride they want to
ride around their home um municipalities
have had control over their own roads
for over 50 years and a lot of
municipalities have opened up their
class six roads to ohvs over 50 years
ago and those are
longstanding um uh ordinances it was
2014 that they added class five roads
and four roads and it was
2017 that they added class one roads and
two roads um which is what connected the
major riding areas up North so the towns
in the central and southern part of the
state are like hey they're getting that
benefit up there why don't we have this
benefit and over and over I had to say
well on a state road you can't do it
unless you're in Grafton and Coos County
they're like but we've opened up all our
roads the RSA even says that we have
control over all the roads in our town
limits except for that state road so all
we're doing is asking to add these five
other counties where I have received
calls from uh different individuals and
towns on trying to get on these small
sections it's not to connect major
riding areas like ride the Wilds was so
this is kind of a unintended consequence
of the tight laws that we did up north
um focused just on ride the wilds and
the the larger riding areas and we would
like to extend that to these other five
municipalities so when the verified mail
came out it was targeted that these
clubs had to pay for that and that was
all fine and dandy when you've got a
club up North with 800 members they make
you know $115,000 a year they can afford
it but some of our clubs down in Central
and Southern New Hampshire only have 40
50 members in their their their club
with 10 miles of Trail um and they need
a half a mile a road to connect their
their riding areas so we we're not
talking about making a ride the Wilds
south or connecting all the riding areas
we're just giving back local control to
these municipalities to open up their
short sections of Road through a
rigorous permitting process which starts
at the town with notifications a butter
notifications public hearing then with
all that paperwork um apply to Bureau of
trails once Bureau of trails goes
through their list then they pass it on
to uh do they go through their list
Department of Safety gets a look at it
and then the it goes back to the town
and the town uh allows it to be opened
so the the process is very very
intensive um not every town is going to
go through this they're they're not
going to make big connections but some
of these towns that their residents just
want to get to the gas station to put
fuel in or they want to get to the to
the landfill to to put their trash there
and and really we're not using roads for
recreation we're really using roads for
transportation and because New Hampshire
has really dug down in the definitions
we we put ourselves into these really
tight boxes and I would just like to
encourage you to um pass this bill so
that the local municipalities can have
the power and control um upon themselves
you know it it doesn't make it so that a
club can't pay for the
notifications but if you have a resident
who just wants to get to his is class
six Road um why why should that one
person have to pay for notifying all his
neighbors just to get to that class six
road so we we we would like to to not
have to have the petitioner pay every
time especially when it's just a a
resident or two um to do that um in
Claremont where my local Club is we um
used to go to the city every year for
permission they would sign a permission
form when the butter notification law
came to be in
2019 um we had to go back and for a mile
and a quarter road we had the city send
out 297
notifications it cost our Club close to
$1,000 to get notified for a mile and a
quarter of Road um they included all the
class six rows that were already open um
out of the
297 notifications some of them it was
two or three per residents so a married
couple that was two notifications so we
had to pay that double um
notification at the hearing 11 people
showed up to to to just be there out of
the 11 people six spoke out against it
and only two of those people who spoke
fol against it lived on that mile and a
quarter road so out of almost 300
notifications we really had two abutters
along that whole section who spoke out
against it the city council passed it
the club was was able to pay and do that
now we have four other ways up into what
we call the cat hole Trails but the club
doesn't want to spend you know that
money to just let the residents access
that
we have our road from our parking up to
there um but when residents want the
access it should be the residents who
maybe pay for that notification process
the other thing we have in Claremont is
at the racetrack they just built a
campground the campground owner reached
out to the club and said hey we want to
connect to the cat hole but there are 60
residents along that road and at doesn't
do anything for the club but the
campground wants access so um who who
pays would it be the club or the
campground
so when it's up in the air like that
then nothing happens and so it it just
seems like um it's it's been targeted
the clubs have been targeted
unfairly um because it was all based on
what's Happening up north and not what
is happening in these individual small
places in Central and Southern New
Hampshire so that would conclude most of
my testimony um we have written
testimony but uh as I said I've
highlighted all the important points on
how the processes are covered under the
RSA and there is a um five or six page
um
application process this outlines all
the things that the clubs and the agent
state agencies have to do uh to go
through that permitting process I didn't
do all the copies of this because it's
just so much um but we can email that to
the committee if they want to hear or
read any questions from Mr
wilky representative Bri thank you Mr
chair thank you for my question um as I
understand it this
uh practice is already in use up north
and this bill simply
allows other municipalities counties to
use the same
practice this bill if passed does not
open up the wild west on roads it
doesn't it actually if passed doesn't
even increase
ohrv Trails one mile unless people go
through the practice that's in here I
just wanted to make sure that was clear
yes that is correct 100% this will not
open up any bit of Trail all of it still
has to go through process you still have
to get landowner um permission which is
the municipality then if it's on State
Road then Bureau
Trails okay and Dot thank you ERS of n
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question just to clarify you think
the cost of the notification toter
should be born by the
municipalities is that correct yes so it
it's requires verified mail uh verified
mail is just proof that it was mailed
it's not certified mail um some people
can't uh grasp the difference between
certified certified you get a receipt
saying the person signed for it this
just proves that it was mailed which a
municipality has to keep track of anyway
for the right to no law they have the
list of people that they sent so we're
kind of like paying for it twice um just
the post office giving a receipt that
these did get actually mailed when the
municipality has to keep track of all
this data
also any other questions from Mr wilky
representative
Taylor thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking the question the bill adds
five counties to the two existing for
this do you have any idea how many towns
in those five counties would be impacted
by this well there none would be
impacted I mean those towns can open up
their roads already there is that
process all this does is adds the state
roads that might go through that town to
be able to be opened as I stated the the
town of Washington the town of Cen the
town of Windsor and and antrum I have
heard from all four of those towns that
they have their roads open already and
they just want to connect them so I I
can't imagine that this legislation
would encourage other towns to rush out
and open up their roads just to get on a
small section of State Road this really
is only speaking about state roads as
far as adding the five
counties you're welcome representative
Vil thank you Mr chair um thank you for
taking my question so we're adding five
counties and what about um Rockingham
and bellnap counties why aren't they
included in the bill so I um suggested
that these five counties um because
these are counties where I have actually
heard people call and say I am here we
would like this here um I didn't hear
from anyone in Rockingham County or the
other County so that is how these five
were chosen because the towns have
already opened up their roads and they
just want Road use so it was
strategically chosen from the
demand thank derby um thank you for
taking my question as I understand the
statute um currently the towns can
already open up their sidewalks adjacent
to these state roads as well so they
have an option for example to put in a
sidewalk if they chose to open up this
access
already um I don't know the process of
installing sidewalks on a state road but
I could imagine that would be um a much
larger debate but if there was a
sidewalk there sidewalks have been able
to be used for many many years even
before we were allowed on any of the
roads so that has been in statute a lot
longer than any of the road
use anyone
else saying none thank you Mr Wilkey
thank you and I was the one that said 10
minutes
so was pretty close to 10 if not longer
thank you very much for
listen opposed to the bill an Davis uh
New Hampshire Farm Bureau and New
Hampshire
TOA
and and she has test
testimony good afternoon representative
chairman harb and members of the
committee my name is an
Davis and I am a resident of wilmet and
I own a wood lot in
Springfield uh I am here today to
testify in opposition to house bill
um I am a member of the New Hampshire
Timberland Owners Association and the
New Hampshire Farm Bureau Federation and
represent these two Statewide landowner
organizations on the HB 1188 ohrv study
commission this commission as you
probably know was established in 2022 to
find ways the state of New Hampshire
could mitigate conflicts between
motorized and non-motorized Trail users
as a forest land owner on occasion we
use an ATV when doing management work on
our property the machine is a useful
tool and can access the wood lot where
using our tractor is Not
Practical um in
2024 the American Tree Farm
Federation uh noted my husband and I as
one of four top tree farmers in the
United
States I'm opposed to this bill for
several reasons including the bill
states that abutters will be
notified however because it's
unclear in my mind anyway in the in the
writing of the bill the petitioning
party no longer must bear this this
expense is it the sponsors intention
that municipalities should shoulder this
cost if yes is that fair when these
entities also will bear additional costs
for law enforcement Road repairs Etc
resulting from a change use the
petitioning organization should bear the
notification cost law enforcement ask
virtually any law enforcement officer
including the police chief in willment
and he will he or she will readily admit
that their department whether it's a
town County the state of New Hampshire
or fish and game does not have the
Staffing to address current enforcement
issues on Trails expanding the
opportunity for Ohr V use on state roads
in Caroll chesher Hillsboro marac and
Sullivan counties could increase the
workload for these law enforc ment
folks uh who do not have the Staffing to
take care of the work that they already
have um as a matter of fact in Coos
there are 17 people per square mile
Grafton County 55 people per square mile
in comparison in Sullivan there the
population density is 82 people per
square mile in chesher County it's
110 Marram County
69 and Hillsboro County
338 so the possibility for a butter
impact if this were changed and yes it
would be approved through the town but
the change would cause an impact on
these higher density
counties
safety I think it would be dangerous to
allow ohvs on state class 1 2 3 and 3A
roads in these in these counties these
roads are larger they have faster speed
limits and they are mostly
paved and finally as a member of the
ohrv study commission and I've been so
for more than two years uh the
commission has eight duties including to
study the pos positive and adverse
effects of ohrv use on state and town
roads including class 5 and class six
roads I've included a copy of that uh
commission's uh directives in my
testimony furthermore the commission is
supposed to report its findings and
recommend proposed legislation to the
Speaker of the House of Representatives
the president of the Senate the house
clerk the Senate clerk the governor and
the State library on or before November
1st of each year this has not happened
although we have been informed of some
ohrv bills members of the commission
have not had an opportunity to engage in
an in-depth discussion of any o ohrv
bills that have been brought before the
New Hampshire legislature this session
the chairman of the commission who also
is the lead sponsor of House Bill 683
should have given the commission members
an opportunity to vet this bill before
was assigned to your committee he did
not I urge members of the House
resources Recreation development
committee to determine that house bill
683 is inexpedient to legislate thank
you for considering My Views and
concerns and thank you all also for on
behalf for your work on behalf of all of
New Hampshire's residents it's always a
pleasure to be able to have an
opportunity to share our opinion before
this body thank you any questions any
questions for Miss
Davis thank you sing none thank you for
your testimony in support of the bill
Jonathan
Pat
Pi you got it okay thank you resident of
Washington assume not DC right
hello ladies and gentlemen I am John P I
am from Washington you heard that name
passed around quite a bit if you don't
mind I'm going to show you real quick
something that my town um government
planning board which I am a part of um
put out for the residents of our town
our town is comprised of a a lot of
local residents and we also bring in a
massive amount of people from
Massachusetts and and Connecticut and
they all recreate in our town um and
that's a a big part of our um economy um
I I work as a carpenter I work for a lot
of those people that are coming up
recreating um so the town put out a
while ago in conjunction with um a club
in our area this
[Applause]
map this is set up by from the town of
Washington um shows you all these red
lines kind of going throughout U the our
Classics roads which are open to all
ohvs which includes uh four-wheelers
side by sides and and of the like
the green line going straight through
this is directly from our town is the
state road and it divides our town and
this not to um reiterate what Steve
Wilkey was saying but we are one of the
towns where a state road goes through
and it
is a known thing that if you go on the
State Road between Valley Street and old
Marlo road which is a 30 m hour yeah the
people will look the other way and to me
that's not okay we we we are trying to
get to the general store which has a gas
station fueling um so mobiles have a
trail that goes directly there right
across the state road um ohvs are
technically not allowed um we have
multiple lakes around the area um a lot
of Summer Camps summer residents um they
are mostly using um side by sides to get
around town um I have spoken to um our
chief of police Muro um our policeman um
Mark dressle uh our fire chief um and
our our um Bo excuse me not don't have
anything in front of me uh the Town
garage the Ed theer he's he runs Our
Town garage and takes care of the roads
and they are all in favor of of opening
up our roads and getting links to these
Trails which are Classics roads we have
a great network of Classics roads I use
them um multiple people use them walking
and Etc but the the State Road in
between is blocking us um and we would
like to have the opportunity to be able
to explore the the possibility of
opening that up and making it actually
legal uh whereas the snowmobiling is
getting smaller and smaller the our
general store is getting less and less
people coming there for during the
winter making it harder for him to stay
open um and bringing in
this state road into some use in the 30
mph zones at least we can achieve a
little bit more income coming into that
General Store and we don't want to lose
our general store we want to open up the
roads that that are applicable do it
responsible with a good signage working
with the the police our Police
Department um our police department and
fire department both have gotten grants
for side byid so they can get out onto
the roads if they need um Muro uh he's
the chief of police he worked in in um
um henker opening the trails there
and he told me that he was surprised on
the lack of incidents that occurred in
that area he was kind of against it at
at the F first and so he's on board in
Washington bringing on board to to
connect those trails and opening up
certain corridors just to make links to
our classic roads and that does pertain
to some state
roads so that is basically my bit
thank you any questions for Mr
P don't see any thank you very much for
your
testimony opposing the bill Gary
Newfield from
Randall Mr
Newfield thank you chairman committee
members I appreciate the opportunity to
be here my name is Gary Newfield I live
in Coos County in the town of Randolph
and I've seen firsthand the conflicts
that have Arisen with with ohvs in the
general public I'm the chairman of the
Randolph Conservation Commission and on
this local Zoning Board of adjustment
and I'm a member of the ohrv study
commission representing the New
Hampshire Association of conservation
commissions I write an opposition to HB
683 I feel that this bill is an end run
around public notice by taking away
certified mail notification of a Butters
when a landowner wants to make changes
to their property a butter notification
is key to making sure that citizens are
aware of changes to their community ohvs
have a huge impact on the makeup of the
community through which they travel an
appropriate notification by certified
male should remain the standard way to
communicate with affected
citizens we all know that fish and game
and local law enforcement are underst
staffed therefore opening more roads
ohvs is nothing short of a recipe for
disaster the ohrv commission is well
aware of this as it is a frequent topic
of
discussion Paul D party past
Commissioner of fishing game when
dealing with conflicts between
snowmobiles and nonmotorized Recreation
has said the way to end the conflict was
to separate the users ohvs are designed
to be used on Trails not roads not in
close proximity to homes where they
disturb the peace and quiet of the
neighborhoods also in the North Country
a Butters have given up filing
complaints about ohvs because of the
lack of law enforcement by the time the
complaint is filed the ohvs are long
gone Andor there are no law enforcement
officers available expanding ohrv
activity in this current environment is
just plain wrong and would do a
disservice to the general
public the state also has spent
thousands of dollars litigating
omv's disruption of a neighborhood in
gorm New Hampshire if the state had
followed Paul D's pesent thoughts this
is this issue would never have occurred
p mage of this bill will only exacerbate
the continuing conflicts of ohvs versus
homeowners the state is entering a time
of fiscal uncertainty and this is no
time to be opening the door for more
lawsuits I therefore am opposed to HB
683 and ask you to oppose the
Bill thank you sir any questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you in support of the
bill Jerry
Livy say it right from Keen
representing an ATV
Club good afternoon everybody in the
committee um I just try to keep it short
uh I represent the mount Pisa ATV Club
where we have uh two Trail systems one
in Winchester and Hampshire one in
Hinsdale um we operate a very extensive
uh trail system in Pisa State Park
um where we have uh also upgraded uh the
trail system there uh we share that
trail system um with u hikers Walkers
equestrians snowmobiles and dog sled
mushers uh because of the effort that we
put into that trail system all those
user groups have had uh success in um
using um the upgraded trails with uh
Bridges and um resurfacing Etc we've
been able to raise in the last six years
over
$237,000 uh in donations and state aid
um and through a volunteer effort have
been able to make quite an impact on
both Trail systems as a club um we have
uh seven miles uh in between the two uh
Trails where we have landowner
permission to um make a connector Trail
which will cross cross just simply one
short road on Route 63 and then we have
asked the town of uh Hinsdale to exit um
119 on the North Hinsdale Road uh to be
able to access gas and um some
restaurants um and a few other uh
municipalities on that side so basically
um we feel that as the club we've had a
pretty good impact on uh upgrading
Trails bringing economic um uh boost to
both the uh Winchester town and hensdale
town we have a lot of residents Town
officials that um support us and we feel
that as a club that this particular
House Bill uh with allowing uh some Road
Crossings and connector Trails which are
usually uh very short and um mileage
would uh benefit our particular club and
the two towns that's basically it
anybody got any questions questions for
the speaker representative Sergeant
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I was just wondering
do you charge members
dues yes and have you had any problems
paying up followup Mr chairman follow go
ahead have you ever had any problems
paying for the abutter notices on these
changes that you've just talked about no
than any other questions for the speaker
seeing none thank you for your testimony
okay thank
you and I'll just mention I have eight
pink cards and they're all opposed so I
don't have any more in support so we'll
call you up uh Walter Payne in
opposition good afternoon chairman and
members of the committee um I'm going to
start with a question uh why isn't
anyone in this room smoking or vaping
there are probably 40 people here right
there's got to be one who wants to uh
well the reason of course is that uh New
Hampshire in about 1990 25 years after
Surgeon General report and about 10
after secondhand smoke was shown to be
bad for other people too uh they passed
the indoor smoking act uh behind the law
is very simple idea everyone's actions
should take into account their effects
on others it's basically the Golden Rule
which is part of pretty much every
religion you can think of in recorded
history another way of thinking about it
is your right to walk down the street
swinging your fist stops at the point of
my nose or in this case your right to
drive a noisy vehicle stops at the drums
of my ears so um economists uh it's the
same idea as being a good neighbor and
economists talk about neighborhood
effects to refer to things that are
either good for the other people in the
neighborhood like planting beautiful
flowers that every could enjoy or having
you know emitting air pollution that
everyone in the neighborhood gets to
breathe regardless of whether they're
getting paid for producing or not so um
another use term they use for them is
externalities and they can be there good
or bad positive or negative so
consistent with our state motto we let
adults ride motorcycles without helmets
we let adults drive cars without seat
belts the idea is that those choosing to
do so are only endangering themselves
there are no negative externalities from
their actions which are obviously from a
statistical standpoint not great for
human health right um now you can argue
whether there are negative externalities
here because if someone goes through a
windshield in the state of New Hampshire
any hospital he's taken to has an option
has a obligation to try to put them back
together as well as as best as they can
and regardless of their ability to pay
so in many cases it does end up in the
insurance company's hands or the
government's hands and of course it ends
up in the insurance company's hands it
ends up in all of our in all of our
premiums so that's a debatable point but
we'll ignore that for the time being so
HB 683 poses the same question as lots
of government policies how do we weigh
competing interests how do we weigh the
winners versus the losers in this case
those who enjoy riding ohvs which I'm
sure is a blast I mean driving a car on
a windy road is is one of the great joys
in life uh you get to do it on a trail
where you can go where you want you can
get airborne sometimes I'm sure it's I'm
sure it's great fun um uh and and so do
we want to make it essentially easier
for them to do it in more places or
literally to reduce the cost of it as
has been referred to in previous uh
testimony about uh notification
requirements and obviously when you
reduce the cost of something you're
going to increase that right that's just
basic um
so what are the principles here
um uh there's a guy an economist named
Coast who showed that private
negotiations could in fact produce
efficient out output out outcomes in
this sort of situation so let's say a
guy named Joe who wants to start raising
chickens on his property in a
residential neighborhood and he has four
neighbors who would be able to hear the
chickens and uh if he's going to make
500 bucks a month and he can and each of
the four neighbors is satisfied with
receiving $100 a month to put up with
the new the noise then he's going to do
it he's going to get 500 pay out 400
still having a $100 profit right but if
the four neighbors say no no no I need
150 so to be woken up every morning then
you're up to 600 bucks he's only going
to make 500 he's not going to do it so
you get an efficient outcome I.E the
greater productivity if it leads to
Greater productivity it happens if it
doesn't it doesn't happen now the
problem we have of course is that as
soon as you get past a very small group
of people involved it's impossible to
negotiate everything right so for
instance we couldn't replace the Clean
Air or or water ax
with interrupting you um I appreciate
your analogies but can you be more
specific to the bill
focus on the bill there are other people
that would like to speak also sure so so
in this case obviously you're not going
to be able to negotiate between the
hundreds or thousands of ohrv riders who
are going to go on these roads and the
equal or larger number of people who are
going to be passed by their houses by a
vehicle that is statutorily allowed to
be 96 DB and of course as we know with
Automobiles and kill switches and
aftermarket mufflers and all that can be
far higher than that okay
so there's there's no way for the O RV
drivers to obtain the consent of or to
offer compensation to the people they're
harming and I'm just talking about the
noise because that's the easiest one to
talk about there are I'm sure other
negative externalities so how how should
legislators weigh these competing
interests well a guy named maner Olson
wrote a book called um logic of
collective action and he made an
important point which is that if you
have a a concentrated group of winners
against a large but smaller uh more
diffuse losers the small group of
winners is likely to win in in in
politics because they're going to have
the incentive to devote a lot of their
resources to lobbying so that's
basically why we have billions a year
spent on biof fuel subsidies even though
no Economist
agricultural farmer everyone knows it's
a scam but it persists because the Iowa
Corn Farmers have the presidential what
was it caucus to demand that sorry I'm
going to have to interrupt you again
appreciate the chickens and the
Iowa just get to the Bill thank here we
are so the bill cannot be whether it's
good or bad policy cannot be Jud by how
many people support it or don't support
it because the people who support it are
getting to going to do their favorite
thing in life or maybe second I don't
know you know their favorite more at at
someone else's expense whereas all the
people are going to hear a vehicle every
five minutes every 10 minutes depending
on where you live they're going to lose
just a little and they probably don't
even know about this law but I assure
you every ohrv Club in New Hampshire
knows about this law La so that's the
okay leaving aside these general
principles just a couple practical
issues as I said they there's a 96 deel
limit on
ohvs but uh that's pretty loud to begin
with but we all know that engines can be
tuned and driven a certain way they're
going to be a lot louder than that and
there are no annual inspections and even
on automobiles which do have annual
inspections at least where I live
there's no limit to the number of people
with their tuned Audi's or Hondas want
to tell me on Friday night or Saturday
night that they can easily go over 100
dbel as they accelerate past my house
and I've talked to police about this
most towns do not have a deciel meter
which by the way takes two police
officers with certification to operate
it and all that so it's much harder to
enforce in speed and we're not enforcing
it for cars at least where I live I
don't know about where you live cars or
trucks and and I don't see how we're
ever going to enforce it for ohvs
secondly um the law talks about
obtaining the permission of a Butters
now the notion of a Butters makes sense
if you're talking about putting a up a
fence like it can't be too ugly for your
neighbors but if you're giving
permission for someone to ride vehicles
that could be 100 DB on your property
really the relevant range should be
anyone who can hear it and that's
frequently going to be way more than one
property width unless you're living in
an area with like 50 acres zoning so um
I don't know I mean ultimately the
question and it's it's unfortunate but
some hobbies are just more annoying than
others can you draw you ask for three
minutes and my clerk tells me you've way
gone beyond three minutes so so the
basic question is does Live Free or Die
mean that people are free to do what
they want regardless of the harm to
others or does it mean that residents
are free to enjoy the quiet enjoyment of
their homes without a very good reason
like a a a fire ambulance or a truck
delivering needed supplies and just as
for the second speaker the second
speaker is explicitly arguing that the
government should somehow
subsidize uh new permitting for ohvs now
the government generally subsidizes
things that have positive externalities
we pay for K through 12 schooling so
people will be able to get a job and not
become criminals we pay for public
vaccination because that's thought to
provide health benefits but why would
the government subsidize something that
has basically negative externalities it
just doesn't make any sense um and I
think that's about it but thank you for
your time any questions any questions
seeing none thank you for your test one
final thing climate change is obviously
the mother of all negative externalities
and it has to be uh acted on by pricing
carbon thank you thank
you speaking against it uh Captain
Eastman from New Hampshire fishing game
Captain
Eastman thank you Mr chair and committee
um I am here here are the behest of the
uh fishing game committee and uh they
are opposed to this bill um they opposed
for several reasons I can certainly go
over those um I've been o rvy
coordinator uh for going on six years
and in those almost six years we have
worked to uh get ohvs off the road um
for instance uh just a couple years ago
passed a bill that if a ohrv was
registered for the road um it could not
register as a recreational vehicle and
this was really to um thwart the Montana
plate issue for which someone could ride
on any road
unregulated um and uh would really put a
black eye on the ohrv community so I'm
not really speaking about the first part
of this bill and uh and notifying the
abutters I'll leave that to Chief reny
to speak to um I guess my biggest
question about this bill and expanding
ohrv use on highways is that
um in my six years one of the biggest
complaints especially when I came in
here uh was uh Road usage of
ohvs um I I think to say that it's been
successful in Coos County is uh is is
not true uh the town of dummer decided
within my time to close their roads due
to the complaints um of their res
residents um and once again just just a
couple weeks ago we were here speaking
about how uh depressed um the Coos
County uh is and how uh ohrv use in that
county uh brings in so much revenue to
them um that we uh needed to open up 10
a half miles of the headwaters property
uh for use of
ohvs um but now two weeks later
there's enough to go around to every
other County and we should open up those
counties I just don't understand that if
um if this is really helping Coos County
then why is it not helping it out or why
are we introducing a bill that would
take or deter or take money away from
that County um and I I think that's just
one question that you may not hear um so
I think the long and short of it is is
that uh this uh This original law was
was part of ride the Wilds ride the
Wilds um in my opinion uh was was thrust
upon uh the state uh without uh a whole
lot of planning and I think that uh we
don't want to make that same mistake
again um the HB 1188 ohrv commission
really was established to look at issues
like this and come up with Solutions um
so
um to finish up here that's really why
the fishing Game Commission is opposed
to this uh this Bill thank you Captain
questions representative Darby thank you
Mr chair uh thank you Captain Ean for
taking my question based on your
experience if the state roads were
opened up um to be connectors between
Trails would the overall um ohrv usage
increase I can't say that it would
increase um I can say that um if it came
down to um someone who was looking to
come to New Hampshire to operate an O
HRV and they had the choice of going to
Marram County if they were coming from
Massachusetts let's say and ride in that
area as opposed to going all the way to
Coos County that's I think where you're
going to see the difference is that
you're going to move from those other
counties that are currently open to um
you know to those lower counties says
why would you drive another hour and a
half if you can get the same bang for
your buck in the lower
counties any other questions for Captain
Eastman seeing none thank you Captain or
did you have a
question so you're all set with Captain
Eastman because the poor guy's sitting
there thank you okay thank you Captain
you have a question to the chair thank
you Mr chair I was just wondering if
someone from dot is here today that is
we have someone from do that says they
will ask question they will respond to
questions if there's only if there is
any questions so as chair I've kept this
card out here cuz I thought would' hear
the testimony of the other people first
and then we'll ask the board if they
have any questions of do if you don't
have any questions and it's not going to
testify good question though thank you
opposed as I said the rest of these are
opposed uh Abby IA from gorum
representing herself Abby
and my clerk was very interested in this
but you might ask and watch how come the
clerk left because he's uh bringing a
bill at another session so he's got to
leave and he'll be back okay thank you
those are watching um my name is Abby
vano uh from gorhum today I'm speaking
to you as a private citizen who knows
too many friends and neighbors across
New Hampshire who've lost the peace and
quiet of their homes to the noise and
dust of misplaced ohrv trails I would
say that the process leaves a Butters
out of the process and it it leaves a
Butters of state roads out of the
process right now there is no
notification if you live along a state
road if it's going to be opened up to
ohvs yes there's a public hearing but if
you live there you do not get anything
telling you that your road might be an
ATV trail you just have you have to see
the little box in the back of the paper
which might
have if you even have a paper so um
state roads those citizens do not get a
butter
notification uh unfortunately the way
ride the Wilds rolled out without any a
butter notification to town or state
roads success for Riders has meant
losses for residents be this process has
not served residents um once a road is
open it's not open to just a few
residents it's open to anyone who shows
up that's a very important um unintended
consequence um the problem and Coos have
not been solved um the people there are
still waiting for their peace and quiet
to be returned um as former chairman of
this committee Andy Rulo likes to say a
family's home is their castle and it
must be defended HB 683 is a property
rights issue people have the right to
the peaceful enjoyment of their property
and they have the right to know if a
significant change in use is proposed at
their property
line um to end
petition or payment of butter
notification makes no sense who will pay
this sounds like an attempt to undermine
the abutter notification when it needs
to be strengthened to include those on
state roads the abutter notification was
passed I think in 2019 after Coos
residents came and complained that was
the one protection they were able to
pass going forward they haven't regained
their peace and quiet they still they
cannot open their windows in the
summer they can't put out they stop
putting out the their lawn and patio
furniture they've stopped inviting
family and friends over for summer and
barbecues and they make plans to leave
their homes on weekends to escape the
noise dust and fumes of ATVs that have
taken over their neighborhoods 5 months
of the
year um members of the Sullivan I it's I
I'm a friend of the one of the Neighbors
in Claremont who listened to the 4 to
500 ATVs roaring past his home to go to
cat hole and he um
when Sullivan C when the Sullivan County
ohrv Club sends out patrols to help
manage the traffic which they do but
they have no law
enforcement uh Authority but they do try
and calm the traffic they tell him I
would not want this going past my home
and that's the point living along an
ohrv Trail is loud and
unpleasant please come to one of these
neighborhoods please come to one of
these homes and visit it and experience
it for yourselves and talk to these
homeowners even riters want to go home
to peace and quiet please vote to kill
HB
683 thank you any questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you for your
testimony uh also opposed Matt Ley
Forest
Society thank you thank you Mr chairman
um for the record I'm Matt Ley I'm the
public policy director for the Society
of protection of New Hampshire Forest
I'm I'm passing around two letters one
is a joint letter from uh nature
conservancy Appalachian Mountain club
and four society and opposition to the
bill the second letter is from Paul
Dosher who um is a member of the OHV
study commission and and is our
representative on that body I'm not
going to read the letters but I just
wanted to make a couple
uh short points um so first we do
understand that you know some view ohvs
as you know important to the economy
especially up in Coos but you know as
you've heard
from some of the prior speakers that
view is is is not shared I mean there is
ongoing conflict and concerns by
Property Owners um abutters to the
trails and so our concern with the bill
is that and and we do view the bill as
an expansion of the um o system in New
Hampshire so we're doing that at a time
when we have not come to a consensus on
how to manage the trail and how to you
know balance the good points and the bad
points um from this so you know uh
several speakers have mentioned the um
this OAB study commission and you know
our three organizations did support the
creation of that commission and it was
done really with the expectation that
the commission would be sort of the
starting point to sift through all the
issues um that are that are happening
now um so you know I think you know we
would encourage the committee to either
um vote this bill itl or to maybe retain
it and have this the um
commission really look at the intent and
issues um with the bill and and you know
really try to sus out the benefits and
impacts before passage so with that I
will close thank you thank you for your
testimony any questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you thank you
also an opposition Katherine corkery New
Hampshire sier Club
Katherine thank you sir um my name is
Katherine corkery uh from New Hampshire
Sierra Club uh I represent about 11,000
members and supporters in the
state and uh we to oppose this bill
um for uh the first section um removing
the petitioner as the um
Financial um uh the person responsible
for
notification um it without
replacing um someone uh is very reckless
in our view
um petitioners uh whether they are a
club or an
individual um are the ones who are
bringing forth this proposal and um it
seems very reasonable that they would be
responsible for
notification um that's how um
our experience has been in other uh
petitioning
situations um we also see this as a cost
shift from the user to the
community um the community is not
necessarily um the ones involved in the
activity I think about like a a
driveway and when someone goes to the
town they are responsible for their
driveway and they're responsible to
notify their neighbors um this is a very
similar kind of use the petitioner
should be the one responsible for
notifying everyone along that roadway of
this major change of
use um secondly um this the uh
expansion of ATVs on state roads oh um
and sorry about
notification I uh want to emphasize what
we just heard from Abby evow that state
roads um or town roads do not have
notification
now
um this is I may have gotten that wrong
I'm sorry uh but uh to only the the
point that only certain roads get
notification
that's not um we don't see that as a
fair application of notifying people
Everyone um all of the abuts on state
roads and town roads should be notified
that's our position um secondly
expanding um the in into the five other
Comm counties um I don't think it's ripe
at this time we have a commission we've
heard um about the commission
they are I liked what Mr Ley called
they're the starting point for this
discussion and um we're waiting for them
to have the discussion and um appreciate
all of your time and I'll end there
thank you any
questions thank you appreciate your
testimony again oppose Douglas Souther
Bradford New
Hampshire do good after
afternoon our family and my name is Doug
Souther excuse me do you want Barbara to
come up with you um are you going to do
separate she can join me want put the
chair in any um she can drag the other
chair drag your
chair
okay so for rec is your wife Barbara my
wife Barbara yes thank you she's also
upos our family actually lives on dirt
roads in Bradford New Hampshire it's the
Confluence of several class six roads
and a class five Road um we have years
of
experience with illegal ATV traffic
which is Extremely Loud and often
driving at excessive speeds directly in
front of our home this activity risked
the safety of our young children and
impairs our quality of life the goal of
this build seems to be to increase off
Highway recreational vehicle
use access to New Hampshire highways by
uh altering the abutter notification
requirement we are acutely aware a why
of why a butter notification is
important on May 7th
2018 prior to the notification law a
proposal to establish an ATV trail on
Bradford's classic roads was made to our
select board by an outof Town ATV Club
there was no public notice of this
proposal other than the select board
agenda on May 14th the chair of the
Bradford Conservation Commission
attended the next select board meeting
regarding a separate issue and learned
about the ATB proposal having been
forewarned of ATB problems in Warner and
Newberry she aler to the Conservation
Commission members in the meantime the
select board asked for additional
information from the at ATV Club before
moving to adopt their proposal on June
4th a standing room only crowd of
Bradford citizens attended the next
select board meeting and voiced their
concerns meeting minutes reflect that
the board was still leaning towards
adopting The Proposal but wanted
additional information
on June 18th the Bradford Conservation
Commission provided a formal
presentation regarding the advest
adverse effect ATVs would have on the
environment citizen Safety Town expense
and the quality of life for families
living along the trails testimony was
also provided by an officer from the New
Hampshire fishing game regarding the
challenges of ATV enforcement with very
limited resources ources and what the
responsibilities the town would incur by
allowing ATV use on the roads minutes
from this meeting this is all in public
record uh reflect the following while
the board has been leaning toward
supporting the request to let the club
adopt the roads after the feedback and
additional information presented
ultimately the board decided against
approving the at the club's
request removing petitioner payment for
a butter
notification significantly increases the
risk that notification will not occur as
noted above allowing the community to
voice their perspective in select board
decisions can change the outcome
unfortunately it appears that the intent
of this bill is to limit Community
involvement when ATV expansion is being
proposed
we believe this is unfair and we ask for
your help in defeating this Bill thank
you Barber did you want to say anything
more or
just agree with you I just want to say I
it it really
is not very nice to live in a place
where ATVs are going by every every
couple of minutes sometimes there's like
50 of them at a maybe not 50 it feels
like 50 15 of them at a time going by
and you know we have our grandchildren
live with us and yeah it's just not you
know there's pollution there's
noise sometimes there's a lot of
shouting and it's just really does
disturb your quality of life for
sure well thank you thank you both we
should note that Bradford is closed to
atbs on these roads any questions for
the speakers sing none thank you very
much and my last card in opposition
Jason stock New Hampshire Timberland
Owners Association Mr
stock well well good afternoon and it
has been a long afternoon so I'll try to
be brief and I just wanted to touch on
four points that um came out as I sat
here with you in this hearing
the sponsor introduced this bill as a
process Bill and and I want want to
raise that because you've heard process
mentioned a couple times several times
throughout this hearing the process of
notifying a Butters state roads do not
require a butter
notification that process that class
four five and six roads do in fact
require a but a butter notification
state roads do
not also proc process who's who's on the
hook for the
notification that the notification we
can only assume because it's no longer
referenced in the bill that it falls to
the municipality but it would be nice to
have that defined is as as lawmakers you
folks like to tune things in and make it
clear who's on the who's responsible for
what who's who's on the hook for what
cost so I would strongly urge you to
consider including in this that it is in
fact that is in fact if that is in fact
the case in the will of this this
committee include the includeed as the
municipalities I think it's important to
have that
defined um you heard about you heard
about enforcement I'm not going to
belabor that the last piece is process
and you know similar to my testimony on
on House Bill 174 which is the 3500 lb
was the 3500 lb uh o V limit getting uh
weight limit getting increased House
Bill
1188 there was a process established in
htoa Farm Bureau and as you heard others
have invested time money we've asked
members and and others to invest time
and time and effort into participating
in that process this bill Sid steps that
process I think Mr ley's suggestion that
this get retained
and allow that commission to chew on it
decide how to proceed would be
appropriate with that I'll conclude my
testimony it's been a long afternoon and
I don't want to belabor what you've
already heard today but for us we do we
do speak in opposition to the bill as
proposed for those very reasons and I'm
happy to try and answer any questions
any
questions seeing none thank you m thank
you and we have from from New Hampshire
do alen hansam if you could step forward
in the speaker's chair I don't know if
there's any questions but turn uh
representative NAB wondered if you were
here so do you have a question for him
oh okay does anybody have any questions
for the
do representative
Taylor thank you Mr chairman thank you
for the question you have any idea the
approximate maximum safe operating speed
for an off Highway Recreation
vehicle uh no I would not be the one for
that um they are intended for off
Highway recreational use so uh but
um naby tires on pavement I'm not sure
how the performance
is does anyone else have a
question we'll go to representative NAD
thank you Mr chair since I dragged you
up here um we we received a lot of
emails about this bill and a lot of them
mention the impact on roads from having
ATVs orvs on the roads can you speak to
the impact is it different than a normal
vehicle the impact that we would see
would be on the the side slopes and
gravel shoulders okay um not on the
paved surface itself but the uh the
erosion on the sides because it's not
frozen like it is during Snowville use
okay all right thank
you I see another hand on my right
any other
questions no thank you Mr hansam is
there anyone else that wants to speak on
House Bill 683 I'll ask one more time
anyone else
want Mr wilky you've already spoke for
more than 10 minutes I know
iy couple of things two
minutes I'll give you 20 seconds because
you had more than 10 minutes before and
I think we can guess what you're going
to say but I don't know
municipalities are eligible for grant
and aid so any maintenance on Class 5
roads that are dirt they can submit for
gravel for grading um or calcium
chloride for dust control safety on the
state roads the permitting process has
to go through the department of safety
so they will look for safety concerns if
there are safety concerns that would not
happen the law says up to 40 mph roads
specom plates and these machines can
operate on that is in fishing game rules
so we take it as 40 mes an hour and up
is unsafe off highway vehicle was
originally designed as highways which
are elevated high-speed highways these
are not safe on that regular roads they
are okay and safe and manufacturers have
stopped saying these are not safe on
roads they're just not safe on highways
New Hampshire once again has gone Far
and Beyond and called every road a
highway even the class six unmaintained
roads are highways which is what are
these are designed for so um appreciate
that additional testimony thank you very
much hearing nobody new uh we'll go to
representative Sergeant our blue sheet
man and uh online thank you chairman we
have 295 opposed online 37 I'm sorry 295
in favor online 370 opposed on the blue
sheets we have three in favor nine
opposed thank you very much so no one
new approaching the speakers I'm going
to close the hearing on 683 FN thank you
all for your time and patience I
appreciate that and now we're moving on
I think the representative may be here
did he come back he came back here and I
somebody go get representative Schmid
what's his last name Schmid Schmid
Schmidt so while we're waiting I'm going
to call the 130 hearing on HB 691 FM
prohibiting the addition of fluidization
chemicals to Public Water Systems going
to open that hearing and the prime
sponsor is across the hall he'll be
right here
um I have to remember to tell you
something that I tell you
now take
eyes
it's not speaking it's not speaking P
hard oh I'm not
speaking I know we have I
stood by than
so because we have a number of speakers
I'm going to start this hearing on uh
this bill HB 691 and the clerk will be
back in a moment uh the prime sponsor
representative Peter
Schmidt thank you very much Mr chairman
and uh everybody in the room and all the
people whove been waiting outside your
pension is in the
mail but um thank you for sticking
around and I want to start off by saying
that I am not some for the record
represented Peter Schmidt representing
do award one which is Stafford
14 this is my 23rd year in the
legislature and uh I'm not some Johnny
come lately to the question of FL water
fluoridation I first became somewhat
aware of it probably about 60 years ago
literally I read an article in Readers
Digest that raised a bunch of the
controversial issues about water flation
and I said to myself someday I got to
take a closer look at
this uh 20 years ago I was on the
municipal and County government
committee and I was told there was a
bill coming in to permit a new plebis
site or referendum in Manchester because
they'd had one that had passed by about
1% that involved the voters of
Manchester but it didn't involve any of
the collar communities which were also
getting a lot of uh Manchester
Waterworks water um and so they the
eventually there was a suit and and the
the court found that since they were
getting water and they didn't have a
vote which the statute requires they had
to do it
again so somebody said to me you're
going to get the fluoride crazies in uh
in your committee today on that
Manchester
revote well when they came in I I heard
all of them and I didn't hear anybody
that was crazy they had a lot of uh
factual information scientific
information and they all struck me as
very
reasonable um so in any case I and I
have been troubled by some aspects of
water fluoridation ever since because I
did a lot of reading at that particular
time so this just to be clear this is
not a bill about BL Banning fluoride
because I recognize that if if you apply
fluoride to your teeth either with a uh
ordinary fluoride toothpaste and uh uh
and um a toothbrush and you're very
careful that you don't swallow any of
the stuff because says right on the tube
right I couldn't hold the tube up if I
had it here because I'm not allowed to
use prop but it's says right there be
careful not to swallow any
fluoride and if you do what does it say
call your poison control center so
fluoride is poison so is alcohol if you
drink enough alcohol you can kill
yourself in a couple of hours um and and
fluoride is poisoned but carefully used
in the appropriate
way there's no doubt in my mind that the
uh that it will protect your your teeth
to some degree against carries or cavity
tooth
decay so this is not a build to kill
fluide use at all used in that fashion
topically directly applied it definitely
works um the idea is that water
fluoridation it's a is a is a different
breed of
cat so what what do what do why do I
bring this bill again we've had numerous
iterations over the years and for the
last couple of terms some version of a
Flor water fluoridation ban has come
forward but mostly it was a buil to
study it because I do believe that there
are controversial aspects that need
further study but in the
meantime there is a there has been a
court case out in California I believe
that r L with this issue for about 3
years and that court case has been
decided and the Court ruled that the EPA
has got it set to work writing will uh
rules to ban water
fluoridation That's the basis of this
bill um I'm not going to argue the
science because I'm not a scientist even
though I read an awful lot about it but
there are number of people here today
that that are practitioners and in one
form or another
of uh tooth uh protection but also of
Health protection and the I will say
that uh the court case did rule that
that the consumption of floridated Water
by pregnant
women creates a situation where the
fluid acts as a neurotoxin
which clearly by by virtue of
highquality EPA funded studies showed
that it's a neurotoxin that lowers IQ in
of that developing Child In Utero and
continues to harm the developing brain
even after the child is born if the
mother makes the formula with uh
floridated water so I won't take any
questions because I want you to hear
from people who are experts not for me
even if I'm right appreciate that
representative thank you very much uh
just so that everybody knows we do have
people here representing the New
Hampshire Dees and New Hampshire HHS
Department of HHS I'm going to hold them
till last because we'd like the other
speakers in the public to speak first
but I wanted you to know they were here
in case somebody had a question they
might want to ask them thank you uh in
support of the Bill representative Yuri
palazov Mar thank you Mr chair for
the Y po representing May Mark 10 hookit
and D Buton uh I I see on how health
human services and elderly Affairs
committee and as you heard this is not a
new issue some study bills were
suggested in the past uh unfortunately
we were not allowed to study this isue
lobbyist said it's safe and effective
just like this covid vaccine safe and
effective but now we we have new data
Federal data on
neurotoxicity uh of uh these chemicals
and it's unproportionately targeting po
populations uh for example when my my
wife was pregnant uh how many T unborn
baby had zero but unborn baby had
brain neural cells that uh could be uh
targeted by those chemicals uh with uh
uh lower IQ and other uh bad
consequences so uh I I was well off so I
could buy a a water special water for my
pregnant wife so she wouldn't have to
drink
flated water but many of my constituents
they don't have extra money money to pay
for water so they targeted by this
non-consensual
medication uh it's uh uh nonpartisan
issue like as far as I know some liberal
municipalities like K they voted against
uh uh this uh treatment long time ago uh
one concern is chemical levels like when
we talk about mar mar an issue with uh
uh
P like the difference between uh level
that is proven uh uh toxic and the level
that allowed in the water could be like
uh magnitude of difference like
thousands of times difference but with
uh fluoride that difference is is very
low uh uh so that's also uh
concerning and uh with State uh
seeing more issues of Alzheimer's and
low proficiency scores in our Public
Schools uh I I think uh it's prudent uh
to protect uh brains of our population
and stop this uh nonv volunt uh
medication thank you any questions for
the representative representative NAB
thank you Mr chair thank you for being
here representative and for taking my
question um you said there have been
suggest study committees but none have
you we haven't had a study committee in
the house on this yes that's correct
okay thank you they just sorry follow up
follow up they just haven't passed or
been approved yeah yeah yeah it uh it
didn't didn't was not signed into law
didn't thank you anyone else seeing none
thank you for your testimony thank you
next opposing the bill Marco philippon
from allenstone
perfect thank you members of the
committee thank you for taking my
testimony today uh I will uh go back to
what my mother once told me be brief yet
be heard so I know I said five minutes
I'll take less than two um my day job
I'm the water treatment superintendent
for the city of conquered I am also on
the legislative committee for New
Hampshire Waterworks
Association uh and I'm here to say that
uh we oppose the bill as written for
three real specific reasons uh so for
the city conquered New Hampshire
Waterworks Association we support uh
local decision making at the community
level right uh there is secondly there
is a mechanism to stop fluoridation uh
so if any Community conquered wanted to
do that the residents would simply uh
get in touch with their counselors get
on the agenda a referendum vote and then
we turn off the floration if the
community so
decides and uh you know one of the other
things certainly if you understand the
water world it's a very heavy uh heavily
regulated industry so we have folks uh
good customers of M that sit up at the
top of the hill mentioned before Dees
and HHS and these folks monitor these
contaminants if you will for a living uh
so they are very well aware of the
subject much more vers than I am uh and
they are looking at this continually so
uh I believe if there was a
determination that at this time and
again we've I won't bore you with with
all of the science EPA is going to be
looking at this again if it was
determined at this time that it was uh
harmful to the population then it's very
straightforward they would regulate it
out and we would have to comply again
very simple process to stop
floration um so for those reasons we we
oppose thank you any any questions for
the speaker representative NAB thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um you said there you said
there are 12 communities that add fluide
to their public water do you have any
estimate of the number of public water
utilities in the
state that I would know off the top of
my head Dees is here I can probably look
to my left to get a rough number they
1300 systems
okay can we not ask people questions
thank you you'll have an opportunity to
speak follow up with yeah thank you
thank you thank you anyone else
okay thank you very much thank
you supporting the bill says he needs
six minutes but I hope it's a little
less uh Stuart Cooper fluide Action
Network Stuart
Mr
chair thank you my name is Stuart Cooper
and I'm the executive director of the
New Hampshire base nonprofit the florid
Action Network founded in 2000 we're a
watchdog group of over 5,500 medical and
scientific professionals and an
international leader on this topic in
fact we were the ones that just won the
federal lawsuit against the United
States Environmental Protection Agency
that deemed water fluoridation a
unreasonable risk to human health I've
been educating New Hampshire legislature
about the issue for 15 years I wrote the
law you see on page one of my handout
that New Hampshire passed in 2012 that
requires warnings on water quality
reports in Flor communities so parents
don't reconstitute infant formula with
tap water due to overexposure to
fluoride at that time the CDC data
showed that 41% of our teens had Dental
fosis which is over a biomarker of
overexposure to fluoride the new CDC
data shows that number has increased to
70% of our adolescents so you guys were
right and the dental lobbyist behind me
who opposed the bill at the time were
wrong uh now why I'm really here is
because since uh actually in two a
couple years ago this exact same
committee voted in favor of this exact
same bill to prohibit floration 12 to9 I
included the blurb on the back of the
front page so you can see why your your
fellow committee members and even some
of you voted in favor of this bill what
has happened since a lot you were right
then and I hopefully you'll do the same
thing
right now as we speak there are eight
bills in seven other states to prohibit
water fluoridation Utah Senate just
passed their prohibit prohibition Bill
10 to3 and uh Hawaii all eight of the
Big Island water operators have called
for a Prohibition of fluoridation in
November the state Florida State Surgeon
General Dr ladapo came out and called on
all changed Florida's uh guidance
calling for all Florida communities to
end water floration due to developmental
neurotoxicity 12 States currently in the
United States mandate fluoridation eight
of them now have bills to reverse those
mandates the South Dakota bill has
already passed out of the Senate and
right now there's a bill in Arkansas
being heard today more than 40
communities representing over 3 million
residents have ended fluoridation in
just the past 8 weeks floration is
unraveling in the coming weeks I'm
announcing this now because we've
already been in communication with the
US Department of Health and Human
Services in the coming weeks
representatives of HHS at the federal
level are expected to send out an advis
echoing the Florida Surgeon General
recommending that all communities in the
United States and water fluoridation due
to fetal and infant neurotoxicity and
over exposure if we don't pass this law
here in New Hampshire communities will
not be able to act quickly because New
Hampshire law currently requires a long
referendum process thousands of
signatures will have to be collected
City councils cannot make a decision
right now in New Hampshire this will
take years is New Hampshire going to be
among the first states to act or among
the last so why is this happening well
NIH in recent years has funded 10
studies looking at fluoride and
developmental neurotoxicity all 10 found
developmental neurotoxicity at levels
seen in FL day communities uh we the
national toxicology program studied this
exact issue for eight years they
published the report in August the
report found that of the 74 studies on
this issue 64 found developmental
neurotoxicity that's 89% consistency of
the 23 studies that they considered
highest quality 95% of them found
developmental neurotoxicity that's your
National toxicology program a former
director Linda bbom has come out
recently in a statement saying water
fluoridation should end you should not
be adding a developmental neurotoxin to
the drinking
water also this impacted our federal
lawsuit we sued uh the EPA and federal
court it was a eight-year lawsuit the
judge heard many weeks of testimony
hundreds of hours of deposition uh
footage and he concluded that flu water
fluoridation at 0 0.7 poses an
unreasonable risk to human health he has
now required the EPA to promulgate rules
they have three years to do so that
eliminate that risk tasa only allows two
things they can either pass a warning
telling pregnant women and children not
to drink tap water which I don't think
they're going to do or they can end the
commercial sale of fuic acid and other
uh fluoridation chemicals so
fluoridation is already coming to an end
the question is are you going to subject
New Hampshire citizens to three more
years of it I have emailed all of you
and I'm send it again after immediately
following this hearing of our deposition
Clips we have deposition clips from CDC
Representatives who will verify that
what you're about to hear from the
people behind me is inaccurate the CDC
acknowledges that there's no benefit to
infants from water fluoridation that
they cannot site any evidence of benefit
to swallowing fluoridation they have no
safety data on fluoride in the brain the
EPA said the exact same thing under oath
as did the National Sanitation
Foundation as did the American Dental
Association you can watch these clips
yourself in your email the CDC also said
that there's no benefit to children's
teeth if fluoride is swallowed by the
mother and it does not provide benefit
during the first six months of life
you're going to hear that fluoridation
is perfectly safe and effective I
challenge you hopefully one of you will
ask those people saying that to provide
you one randomized control trial study
in RCT the gold standard for evidence
after 80 years of water fluoridation not
a single RCT has ever been conducted on
the safety or effectiveness of water
floration please ask for it they will
provide you do nothing because it
doesn't exist and again the ntp found of
74 studies looking at this subject 64
found harm so there are no studies
showing safety ntp did not find
safety lastly I will point out that New
Hampshire even though we're one of the
least floridated states in the country
and Vermont is actually the second least
FL or among the least floridated state
in the country our states are second and
third in lowest rate of dental decay for
children meanwhile states that are 99%
floridated like Kentucky Minnesota and
Illinois have double the Decay rates for
their children um you know so I guess
I'll happily take any questions if
anyone has any about the lawsuit or
anyone has any about the ntp report but
I would please just urge you to join 95%
of the world and 98% of Europe in
prohibiting water fluoridation we're the
extreme outlier in this situation the
science has changed the experts at least
in toxicology are entirely on board with
with ending water floration and that's
what the science
shows thank you any questions
representative thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question about
the lawsuit entitled or captioned uh
food and water watch Inc uh versus
United States Environmental Protection
Agency uh on September 24th
2024 the judge in that
case who is an Obama appointee and a
former ACLU attorney uh issued an 8 page
findings of fact and conclusions of law
uh which for those who are not attorneys
um which I am uh it's basically the
order the judge's order in the case uh
in January I believe the EPA has uh
filed an appeal of that and it's
currently going up before the ninth
circuit is are you part will you be
participating in that appeal and do you
think that moving now before the appeal
is decided is premature actually I'm
glad you brought up they filed a notice
of appeal so no briefing and no appeal
was actually filed and it was filed by
an EPA administrator who was only in
office for a couple weeks and he was
fired the next day um and the Trump
Administration has already uh put a
90-day hold on all um such appeals and
so that's going to go beyond the date
when they could have the deadline's
going to pass so the appeal it was the
notice of appeal was actually at this
point Moot and meaningless if they do um
appeal if there is some official appeal
by the Trump Administration although I
don't believe there will be because
their HHS has already told us that
they're going to be putting on advisory
telling communities and fluoridation we
will of course fight the appeal yeah one
followup huh that unfortunately for me
that's more of a problem I would rather
have you know if you have the nice
circuit coming out and affirming this
decision I think you've got settled law
pretty solid uh now if that's not going
to happen um I guess my opinion of
things is a little up in the air okay
sorry
anyone else have a question to the
speaker don't see any thank you very
much hey thank you very
much opposing the bill
uh bear with me because I can't read the
writing for your last name Dr
Lori or the clerk can you spell your
last
name hello everyone thank you can you
hear me okay
my name is Lori Rosado I'm a resident
and general dentist serving the greater
conquered area I'm here today in full
opposition of the bill concret
fluoridated water is helping make the
difference between my young patients
needing a regular cleaning and my young
patients needing extensive dental care I
look around this room I know a lot of
you have dental work in your mouth it's
just a fact of human nature of when you
grew up and you didn't have the fluoride
that the kids have today and it's needed
in the water and many of you didn't have
it I see the proof of that every day in
practice as it what I have not seen here
however are examples of neurological
disorders that are connected to the
community water fluoridation and we have
the studies to prove
that such issues are scientifically
linked to Decay scientifically and or
disorders are scientifically linked to
poor diet high levels of naturally
occurring fluide fluoride in well and
other non-regulated water sources and
other unrelated environmental and health
conditions but they're not related to
properly fluoridated water like that
which we drink and conquered in other
areas that are
floridated as a dentist I've read the
national toxicology program's recent
monograph it's lengthy I encourage you
to try to read it there's a lot in there
that is probably you need a science mind
to read it but essentially in there
there's nothing in that document that
even suggests that the standard of 7
parts per million in our water is
unsafe in that study there it states
double that dose to be causing the
issues of neurological disorders of
which we don't do we do 7 parts per
million currently in floridated
community
water certainly a high dose of fluoride
the 1.5 parts per million for example
post health risks just like anything
else someone mentioned alcohol earlier
anything at a high dose is going to
cause health risks the solution for
anyone who's concern that they're
consuming too much fluoride is not to
ban the water
fluoridation which only accounts for
about half of the state's Water Supplies
as the numbers were just said rather
residents should talk to their physician
and their dentist to determine cause the
cause issues that they're worried about
but the evidence-based research that I
receive from legitimate sources the
American Dental Association centers the
CDC the American Medical Association the
wh there's countless University studies
hundreds thousands of them all answer
the questions this bill asks fluoride
and proper dosage is safe and beneficial
for
children if my testimony my testimony
and I feel seem familiar I along with
many of my dentist colleagues have
appeared before you before presenting
this information on multiple
occasions and each time we've had the
same people oppose us and we come to the
same conclusion of its
safety dentists are here to protect
protect the public oral health we gain
nothing monetarily by asking for you to
vote against this bill or by advocating
for local community water fluoridation
initiatives it's simple to me I want my
patients regardless of their financial
situation to utilize every option to
stay healthy I'm committed to the
hypocritic oath
and and a strict code of professional
ethics that bind me to the best possible
care for my patients there's no
scientific evidence or imperative to
Warrant the establishment of yet another
legislative study committee I therefore
ask that you vote this bill in expedient
to legislate thank you thank you Doctor
any questions for the
doctor seeing none thank you very much
for your testimony in support of the
bill Charles
norrath A
KSP American environmental health
studies
project hello uh my name is Chris
nurra um I'm the science director of the
American environmental health studies
project and I've done research on
fluoride for over 30 years I want to
First address the most glaring false
messaging that Defenders of floration
seem to have chosen as their response to
the National toxicology programs report
on fluide
neurotoxicity and the federal Court's
decision that floration poses an unre
reasonable risk of child IQ loss
Floridan Defenders claim there are no
studies finding IQ loss at exposures
relevant to water
fluoridation they say studies finding
harm were only at exposures twice as
high as from fluoridated water
fluoridation in the US has done at a
concentration of 0.7 milligrams of
fluoride per
liter and the false message is that only
studies with con concentrations of 1.5
MGR per liter or higher have found IQ
loss but this is simply not true page
one of my handout shows the recent
systematic reviews of fluoride
neurotoxicity all within the past year
as well as the court decision each of
these considered the evidence from all
studies they didn't just cherry-pick a
few studies that showed what somebody
wanted to
show if you look at the figure on page
two of the out you'll see a chart
illustrating the actual fluoride
exposure levels of all the studies rated
high quality by the
ntp and Page Three is a table of the
data for the
chart of the 23 studies seven found IQ
losses at exposures below 1.5 milligrams
per liter furthermore three of those
were specifically from artificial
fluoridation at 7 mg per liter or its
equivalent from floridated
Salt studies finding IQ loss are
colorcoded with the blue symbol all of
the studies above 1.5 have the blue
symbol and the majority below 1.5
do floration Defenders are simply not
telling you the truth when they claim
there are no studies finding harm at 7
or below
1.5 furthermore their argument that 1.5
is so much above point 7 that it is
irrelevant to artificial fluoridation
ignores basic risk assessment principles
and this is why the federal court
decision ruled that fluoridation at
point 7 poses an unreasonable risk of IQ
loss for children it is scientifically
wellestablished that some people are
more sensitive than the average for any
toxic chemical were not all the same
there should be nothing surprising about
this toxic ologists have established
that a few percent of people in any
population are typically 10 times more
sensitive than the average what that
means for fluoride is that a few percent
of children exposed to oneth of 1.5
milligrams per liter 15 will suffer the
same IQ loss as the average child will
suffer at
1.5 the federal court decision
recognized this and said the court finds
that floration of water at 7 mg per
liter the level presently considered
optimal in the United States poses an
unreasonable risk of reduced IQ in
children there is substantial and
scientifically credible evidence
establishing that fluoride poses a risk
to human health it is associated with a
reduction in the IQ of children and is
hazardous at dosages that are far too
close to fluoride levels in the drinking
water of the
US another argument that you will often
hear hear from Defenders of floration is
that if it is stopped the rates of
cavities would go way up but that is
based on two poor quality cherry-picked
studies in contrast a recent systematic
review examining all the evidence by the
authoritative Cochran collaboration
found that there is no longer any
statistically significant benefit from
fluoridation and at best only about a
one quarter cavity per child
they found that fluoridation
Effectiveness has greatly diminished
over the past 50 years if you turn on my
handout to Pages four and five there are
graphs of their data showing this
diminishment page four is baby Fe baby
teeth and five for permanent
teeth the Cochran review said this
diminishment in fluoridation
Effectiveness is likely because fluoride
toothpaste has become almost Universal
since it was first introduced 50 years
ago with widespread use of fluoride
toothpaste there is no longer any
significant benefit to also having
fluoridated Water and toothpaste you can
spit out so you can avoid avoid the
risks while getting the dental
benefits and I'll briefly explain why
the fluoridation Advocates two cherry
pick studies don't actually support the
claim that stopping fluoridation causes
an increase in tooth decay the two
studies one was in Calgary Canada and
the other in
Alaska what you won't hear is that the
cavity rates in Calgary were going up
even during the years before floration
was
stopped
um they continued climbing gradually
after fluoridation was stopped but they
did not Spike spike unknown factors were
causing cavity rates to climb during the
years before cessation so it is a
misrepresentation to claim stopping FL
ation caused the continuing slow
increase and far from being a spike it
was only about half a cavity per child
and that's the same rate of increase as
in the years before fluoridation stopped
as for the Alaska study well it didn't
measure cavities it measured Medicaid
reimbursements for dental work and what
you won't be told by the Florida
Defenders is that Alaska which gets huge
revenues from the oil industry chose to
greatly increase the Medicaid
reimbursement rates for child Dental
treatments most dentists won't even
accept Medicaid patients because
Medicaid reimbursements are typically
too low but when Alaska boosted them the
med the reimbursement rates more
dentists likely found it was worthwhile
to accept children on Medicaid and they
likely did more procedures because now
they were profitable instead of money
losers C ceing fluoridation in New
Hampshire is unlikely to increase
cavities those claiming it will are
using poor quality and decades old
studies thank you any questions for the
speaker yes representative Ryan thank
you for Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um as a science ski teacher I
just have a question um it says presumed
Hazard and moderate confidence in your
levels of study how many children are we
actually talking about that were studied
uh which are you talking about something
in the hand um it says where did the ntp
find on your six-year floor of
neurotoxicity
evaluation are you are you referring to
something in the sand out um it's on
online your 19 your 2022
study 202 are you talking about me
personally it's submitted by you yes
Chris right
yes I mean i' I've I've done I'm just
cous I've done I did a presentation in
2022 I'm trying to remember could you
quote what I said again so that I can
remember what I said said what did the
ntp find um moderate conference and
presumed Hazard my question is how many
people are we talking about that were
studied oh okay um that was a draft
version the the the ones that were
published recently are are more up to
date um I don't remember the exact
number they did they combined they did
meta analysis which is combining the
studies and there were I think 10,000
children in them and there were about
and they they only did well they did it
for the high quality studies I think
there were about
10,000 um children that was your
question point of clar so point of
clarification there were there were over
10,000 children studies
tested with for these lower
IQs there were in the um dozen or so
high quality
studies uh some of them had 500 kids
some of them had
300 when when you added them all
together there were something like
10,000 and a meta analysis you combine
um results from multiple studies to get
so that just one or two studies you know
don't drive what you can't it's it's the
way to avoid cherry picking is to
combine them I I don't remember the
exact number but it was in the thousands
okay thank you any other questions for
the speaker seeing none thank you very
much thank you opposing the bill Michael
aash ARB that's a you New Hampshire
Dental
Society power
back yes sir
thank you very much I only need about 45
minutes of your time
so
uh uh for the record my name is Michael
arbach I'm the executive director of the
New Hampshire Dental Society first and
foremost happy National Children's
Dental Health month to all of you uh on
behalf of our nearly 1100 member
dentists hygienists assistants and
office staff I'm speaking to you today
in opposition to HB 691 this bill
proposes the outright ban of a practice
that over Decades of research has proven
to be safe and effective in reducing
tooth Cav tooth decay among New
Hampshire's residents particularly the
state's most vulnerable
populations we have been here countless
times each time we have brought oral
health experts with legitimate
scientific data and some of them are
here today as well uh and they have
researched and lent their expertise to
research uh on the health benefits and
risks of fluoride and Community water
fluoridation in each attempt to ban uh
fluoridation most recently 2023 2021
2018 and
2016 the general court ultimately
accepted the same
conclusions in halting such dangerous
legislation first that the carefully
calibrated addition of 0.7 parts per
million to community water safety
systems is safe and helps Safeguard
children's teeth from Decay second that
Community water fluoridation
neurological risks are scientifically
linked to poor diet high uh levels of
naturally occurring fluoride in
wellwater and other non-regulated water
sources and other environmental and
health conditions and third that the
community water fluoridation compounds
and systems used in New Hampshire are
well-maintained and carefully regulated
to ensure health and safety of residents
I've already submitted to the group and
I hope your email is working so you can
look at it uh I an exhaustive list of
recent and uh impactful studies that
pretty much uh counter what has been
presented here so far by some of the
Advocates and I encourage you all to
take a look at those and ask us any
questions in New Hampshire as stated
earlier we have a decision-making
process that we leave to the
municipalities when it comes to
floration in the past some Advocates
have tried to circumvent that process
because they were unable to convince
residents that fluoride was
dangerous in fact uh in residents in do
lonia Manchester and
Conquer many of these uh Community or
actually all of these communities have
chosen not to revisit
floration uh and put it on the ballot
because their children have experienced
the health benefits of floration and
none of the issues that you've heard
about whether it's I Q drops or anything
like that could be attributed to
anything could be attributed to C
CWF put simply this bill is a misguided
solution to a non-existent issue
Community water fluoridation is the most
costeffective method of delivering the
health effects of fluoride to all
members of the community regardless of
age educational attainment or income
level for all these reasons the New
Hampshire Dental Society repres
respectfully requests that this
committee rejects this legislation and
vote it inexpedient to legislate I'll
take your
questions questions for the speaker
representative Sergeant thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question does the Ada or the New
Hampshire Ada have a response to the
court decision uh from September of
20124 thank you rep through the chair
thank you representative for the
question um yes Ada has sent in a
actually was part of the uh motion to
appeal uh it has been actively involved
with that a statement was issued
actually in the uh Washington Post uh
two weeks ago regarding from our
president uh Dr Brett Kesler in Chicago
and uh we continue to Advocate uh with
the APA EPA hopefully that they will uh
reconsider this uh
decision any other questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you for your
presentation and it wasn't 45 minutes so
you did good as they
say uh supporting the bill Lissa texler
for
herself Lissa Lissa tler thank
you you see the red light then you know
hi Lissa
Trexler I'm here in support of HB 691 I
I've been a registered nurse since 1995
and I want to talk about the primary
reasons to cease water fluoridation I
feel like they're self-explanatory at
this point fluoridation is not legal the
FDA guidelines require that drugs be
prescribed by a licensed health care
professional for a known deficiency or
disease with the dosage to be determined
by the patient's age body weight and
other relevant considerations once
fluoride is added to the
water um and and with water fluoridation
we're drinking it eating it and bathing
in it once it's added there's no way of
controlling who receives how much um how
much is consumed so ounce per ounce a
small child consumes as much fluoride as
an adult and um like they've mentioned
in previous
testimony as proponents of fluoridation
um they're they're claiming there's
there's a measurement there's there is
no way to measure
that um fluoridation is not ethical
forcing medication on citizens without
their knowledge or against their will
violates their right to informed consent
to medical treatment this means that
communities are doing to everyone what a
health care provider can do to no one
fluide is not a nutrient there is no
biochemical process in the human body
that has ever demonstrated the need for
fluoride therefore no deficiency is
possible adding it to the water violates
the nberg code for human experimentation
fluoridation harms the environment more
than 97% of fluoride goes down the drain
polluting our waterways and soil thus
harming other creatures and for example
the fluoride runoff in the snow homish
and Columbia rivers in the Pacific
Northwest narcotize the brains of salmon
causing causing them some difficulty
swimming Upstream to
spawn so what is fluoride fluoride is a
Lie the FDA considers fluoride a drug
but the EPA considers fluoride hazardous
material that's because water
fluoridated fluoridation chemicals are
not comprised of the natural occurring
fluoride found in nature of the three
chemicals commonly used hydrofluosilicic
acid is one of the most often added it
is com comprised of Industrial Waste of
the phosphate fertilizer industry among
others and is contaminated contaminated
with lead Arsenic radionucleotides and
other contaminants
another fluoridation chemical sodium
sodium fluoride was first introduced in
the 20th century as rat poison to quote
former EPA official Rebecca hmmer the
solution to pollution is dilution so
rather than paying for the safe disposal
of their Hazmat these companies are
allowed to sell
it there's a growing awareness in the
health care profession that fluoride
ingestion continues to be implicated in
health conditions including but not
limited to dental and skeletal fosis
osteoporosis arthritis bone fractures
reduced fertility endocrine disorders
lowered thyroid function obesity
Alzheimer's dementia lowered IQ insomnia
disruption of the immune system
calcification of soft tissue including
arteries and cancer anyone suffering
kidney disease should never drink
fluoridated
water and uh to quote former American
Medical Association president
Dr Charles hay don't drink fluoridated
water fluoride is a corrosive poison
which will produce harm on a long-term
basis does it make any sense to continue
to pay for this archaic and harmful
practice citizens can choose to use
fluoride toothpaste and fluoride
mouthwash and then they can take
fluoride topical applications and
fluoride tablets and there are other
options as well in collaboration with
their trusted doctors and
dentists I ask that that you um o that
you OTP this Bill thank you thank you
any questions for the speaker
representative
Davis uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question I'm I'm just
curious if we can get a copy of your
testimony yes be online or something
thank you yes thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony and before I forget to mention
it representative Judy Aaron had passed
in written testimony to the clerk it's
been distributed to the members of this
resource committee I just wanted to put
that on the record thank you um my last
card in opposition Gail Brown New
Hampshire oral health Coalition
Gail and Miss Gail's passing out a
written testimony um just so you know
I'll call up uh if there's any questions
for
DHS
DHHS after Judy she passed in
written
yes are we ready yes ready okay um thank
you very much for the opportunity to
join you today my name is Gail Brown I'm
with the New Hampshire oral health
Coalition and if you want to know who
our um governance and leadership group
is they're on the right of your
testimony so take a look at that
um and I'm here today on behalf of our
coalition to oppose the passage of HB
691 I'm going to um name a couple of
points but I'm only going to discuss one
of these today so um don't don't get too
nervous um one reason we oppose this
bill is because we um have followed 70
plus years of science that supports the
effectiveness of opally managed
community water
fluoridation because we have heard from
the former U Medicaid dental director
that eliminating the fluoridation
triggers an increase in state spending
for dental restorative care for children
and I would like to add adults we
haven't talked a lot about adults but
fluoride is very important including
Community water fluoridation across the
lifespan and also um we feel that this
usurps local rule um the decisions about
putting water systems onto a
fluoridation plan does come locally and
we in New Hampshire hold that very very
dear and um neither the state or us
constitutions has given that power over
to the state so um we strongly support
continued local rule I'm going to go
into my fourth point which I is really
what I want to focus on today but I do
want to say to you I also am not a
scientists like Mr Cooper um said he was
not and I am not either but I know
there's scientists in the room if you if
you need to clarify something I
say so the last reason that we um are
opposing this bill is because we feel
that it serves to address a problem that
is still not fully defined by the
sponsors of this bill and we want to
know what are the sponsors and the
proponents hoping to achieve and let me
explain so each year and um Mr arbach
talked about which years bills were
introduced but many of them came over
into subsequent years the New Hampshire
legislature has spent many hours and
many dollars on attacking essentially 12
water districts in New Hampshire that
currently adjust their Community Water
Supplies to carefully monitored fluoride
levels that are chosen or or identified
to balance the benefits and um to look
them versus the risks of fluoride this
does not include so those are hours from
the legislature this does not include
the number of hours spent away from
Clinical care and service by dentists
physicians dental hygienists nurses um
those folks who are here in the room
School administrators teachers attorneys
um Etc that are here putting their time
in to look at this I call this
variations we're here again for
variation on a theme and what do I mean
by that it's been mentioned a couple of
times one is this bill has come in one
form or another to this committee before
we have been to the municipal committee
once or twice we have been to the health
committee multiple times um and so you
know here we are again it's a variation
on a
theme um in New Hampshire under the
local rule residents in those 12 local
community Water Systems did vote to put
fluoride into their water systems and
they adjusted those levels to the Center
for Disease Control CDC guidelines um
what few members of the legislature or
the public know is we don't have just 12
water systems and this figure I'm I'm
using right now comes from the
Department of Environmental Services we
have over
2500 um Public Water Supplies and um
those are some are defined as Community
supplies and some as public not a
scientist don't know the difference but
that number does come from the
Department of Environmental
Services I'm sorry I was a little eager
earlier in pointing out that number um
these 2500 plus Public Water Systems
actually serve municipalities smaller
residential communities large workplaces
institutions restaurants hotels and
campgrounds so since only 12 systems add
fluoride you may think that the others
are registering
0.0 parts per million of
fluoride right we only added to 12 the
others must have
0.0 that is not true and in fact our
supplies our um our water supplies are
dependent upon bedrock and other than
the 12 that um fluoridate all of those
other 2500 plus also have a range of
fluoride and that range of fluoride May
go from um uh
0.1 up to over
4.0 now 4.0 is five times that CDC
number that 7 that's down here Water
Supplies in New Hampshire there are many
that are up hovering around four okay so
so um when the source even at 2.0 that's
three times what we consider the optimal
level so what I'm saying to you in fact
if you're interested um at 2.0 the water
system must notify you as the consumer
so you may want to go home and check
your water system Bill and see if you
are in a public or Community water
system that is having to notify you of a
high higher level than the optimally um
recommended one so um 4.0 is when they
actually have to take action as a water
district and so what happens is that at
4.0 what did we say that was five to six
times just the CDC level they have to
mitigate that and pull that level down
how far down do they have to bring it I
don't know again I'm not a scientist but
all it says is bring it down so I'm
going to say 3.9 3.8 3.5 whatever
they're not bringing it down to Optimal
so if you're following where I'm going
the question should be um not if we
fluoridate but what do we know about the
fluoride in our local Water Systems 2500
of them we know an off a lot about 12
but what do we know about the others and
when do we need to intervene this is a
different story than what this spring is
this bill is bringing forward to you
today so let me just say three facts and
I'm going to wrap it up fact of the 2500
Public Water Systems in New Hampshire
naturally occurring Flor ride measures
from 0.1 approximately to over 4.0 far
far away from the 7 recommended very few
um systems actually naturally hit that
sweet spot of 7 so some of them do some
hit perfect on
optimization fact current state and
federal laws only intervene when levels
hit 2.0 plus notifying you or 4.0
mitigating it down below
4.0 okay so fact three wellwater
wellwater has been discussed today
serves about half of the people of New
Hampshire and most of these households
have no idea what their natural fluoride
level in their well is it's there it's
there they just don't know so if you're
on a well you can get a test kit and you
can find out for your household so um
what is the problem that the sponsors of
this bill want to solve I am not sure if
it's to eliminate the fluoridation of
water is it to eliminate fluoride in
water not sure um as as we know as we
just talked about there's a lot lot 2500
that have floridated levels at un
currently unmanaged levels the only
managed levels are in those 12 water
districts so I Leave You with that
question um on behalf of my constituents
we feel this bill is not ready for
discussion because we're not sure what
we're trying to get rid of and um we
again oppose HB 691 and we request that
you go in expedient to legislate thank
you thank you any questions for the
speaker representative Sergeant thank
you Mr chairman and Gail I see your
signature has a JD after it so I feel
okay ask that I may or may not know
fair enough um but I will find out my my
thought is and I want to know if you
agree or disagree or anything else you
think about it okay um so I agree with
the prior speaker given the current uh
presidency and what's happening that
this decision issued in September 24
from the federal court out in California
will probably not be appealed um fully I
hadn't thought of that change in
administration until it just pointed out
to me um which is unfortunate for me but
the judge ruled that the uh EPA has to
initiate rulle making on fluide that's
the judge's rule that's the standing
order then earlier in the decision the
judge notes that the EPA is afforded in
the first instance the authority to
respond and Regulatory actions can range
from requiring a mere warning label to
Banning the chemical so that's what the
EPA is now if this order stands that's
what the EPA is going to do is evaluate
the range go through rulem which
includes public comment do you agree
that it would be prudent to hold off on
changing our law until that process
runs you're
tough you're tough I will I will be very
honest with you um this is not the part
of law that I practice and so I look at
systems and I look at regulatory systems
what I will say to you very honestly is
I feel it would be prudent to hold off
till we understand what this bill is
trying to accomplish and then decide if
it is within our scope of what we want
to do it's very easy to say 12 systems
are the problem um they can stop
fluoridating
and um because it's not State money it's
easy to say that it's a different
question to come forward and say there
are 2500 systems and the state wants to
take the authority to get the fluoride
out I have no idea what that would cost
so um I didn't answer your question but
I did answer that I think we're not
there yet to work on F any other
question thank
you I don't see any hands thank you very
much for your testimony now I'm going to
ask if they'd come to the witness table
DHHS David GED and Whitney
Hammond they have written testimony
and we still have uh New Hampshire Dees
that will follow and I have no other
cards for or
against hello
um my name is Whitney Hammond I'm the
deputy director for the division of
Public Health Services and I'm joined
today I'm Dr David gret I'm a dental
consultant for DHHS Dental
unit um so I want to I'll quickly go
over the things I wanted to cover and
then hopefully leave time for any
questions that may have come up
throughout the course of
testimony um I wanted to First just
address and give context to dental decay
as an issue in New Hampshire so I heard
some reference to that we have the
lowest rate of dental care you know
compared to other states um there was
some talk about is this a children's
issue or an adult issue so I just I came
with data that our department collects
um just to give a little bit of context
so Dental carries are pretty much one of
the most important significant chronic
diseases among children in New Hampshire
uh around 59% of children right now in
the state have dental decay um and a
number of those individuals have
untreated dent Decay which can lead to
lots of different consequences I don't
know if any of you have had the
experience but it can be quite painful
it can make chewing difficult it can
make it difficult for a child to pay
attention in school um and so it is very
much an active issue in New Hampshire um
the other thing that I think is
important I too have been here many
times testifying on similar legislation
and it's sad to have to say but the
dental Decay rate has increased markedly
since the last time I came and testified
it was down around 35% for our kids and
we really saw a change in that carries
rate during covid when access to care
was uh diminished for everybody in the
State uh in addition we know that Dental
carries are an issue for our adults in
the state um so people may not have
awareness that around 40% of adults in
New Hampshire have lost up to six of
their teeth due to untreat dental decay
and uh topical fluoride and systemic
fluoride which I'll go into a little bit
of the differences um are both connected
with preventing that kind of tooth loss
so uh and then it's around 12% of adults
in New Hampshire that have complete
total tooth loss um which is another
thing at risk when you talk about
removing Community water
fluoridation um a number of people have
touched on it so I won't go too much
into it um just to say that community
water fluoridation is a wellestablished
strategy with 80 years worth of evidence
to show that it is safe at the optimal
levels there was some reference earlier
to a lack of what are called randomized
controlled trials um related to the
health uh effects and safety uh
fortunately we don't need rcts because
we have real life evidence from
populations that have had exposure to
fluoride people may not be aware of the
history of how we came to fluoridating
Water Systems but it was actually
through population studies and
epidemiology where back in the 1930s
dentists started to identify communities
that had far lower levels of dental
decay and they also started to identify
fosis which led them down the path of
saying this is an effective intervention
for arresting tooth decay uh so no there
are not rcts because there's broad
population data which is a much more uh
expansive data set than any RCT could be
um cost has come up a little bit and I
know I'm joined here um to talk a little
bit about the fiscal note worksheet that
accompanied this um part of why Public
Health has promoted Community water
fluoridation as one of our like most
impactful um strategies in the last
century is because it's so incredibly
cost effective so for every dollar a
community invests in community water
floration there's an estimated $20
Savings in Downstream treatment um
I can talk I will talk a little bit
about what uh the division of Public
Health Services does in terms of
providing fluoride to children in
schools but it's suffice to say much
more costly to be applying individual
fluoride treatment to children's
teeth um I do want to talk a little bit
I I haven't heard as much around the
differences between topical and systemic
fluoride application I won't go into the
science um a lot but it's just to say
fluoride isn't naturally occurring
mineral um and part of the mechanism
that it uses is to actually so when you
do topical fluoride application that can
be through toothpaste mouthwash but then
a lot of clinical procedures so we have
Fluoride Varnish we have silver diamine
fluoride so there are lots of different
ways to put fluoride onto a tooth and it
strengthens it it mineralizes it that's
topical uh systemic fluoride which
nobody has mentioned I don't think today
but there are two ways you can get
systemic fluoride one is through the
water
fluoridation um people have also not
mentioned but bottled water is
fluoridated in this country and then all
of the products that are produced using
fluoridated water are fluoridated juices
alcohol um so it's uh broadly in things
um the systemic fluoride actually helps
to strengthen teeth it does topical so
when you're drinking the water it's
topically treating your tooth as well as
it is for children and very effective in
helping to build up the strength of the
teeth that have yet to emerge um so it
is very different um the other systemic
fluoride option would be tablets which
we're going to talk about the cost that
Medicaid projects around having to
provide systemic fluide to Children
through prescriptions from their health
care
providers the last thing I wanted to
just highlight is um New Hampshire is
not unique in regard to our Healthcare
Workforce shortages um and there are
incredible challenges in terms of
Staffing primary care and dental offices
we've seen a 7% decrease in the number
of dentists in the state while we've
seen an increase in the number of people
with dental insurance um you know partly
through the expansion of the Medicaid
benefit to include adult
Dental um so there would be concerns
over even the capacity of the dental
Workforce to be able to serve uh the
increased number of children who don't
benefit and adults who don't benefit
from
fluoride
um I think that is good for me did you
have anything did we did submit a fiscal
note worksheet I don't know if people um
have particular questions around that
um and it breaks down the cost that we
would anticipate for those tablets I'm
happy to take any questions is the
doctor going to say anything did you
want to add anything yes please we start
doing questions thank you thank you
chairman um I'd like I'd like to start
with the with the water fluoridation um
people that are affected and in the
approximately 17 communities that we
have that have the water of fluoridation
there are almost 25,000 children under
the age of
12 and it is this type of systemic um
intake of fluoride that it is the most
potential the most effective at
preventing dental disease from Decay
standpoint um than than adults uh and a
situation if fluoride can be in contact
as the teeth are growing and developing
they become more resistant to Decay so
it's crucial for these 25,000 children
and that's only up until age 12 uh
beyond that we have another almost
46,000 residents um between the ages of
13 and above um that Medicaid covers and
and protects um we are expecting a
significant change in prescriptions for
fluoride if the kids are not going to be
getting the fluoride through their water
then it's going to be done by
prescription and it's done by
prescription by your dentist or by your
physician because that is the standard
of practice so if fluoride is eliminated
from the from the patient uh they will
be added through prescriptions uh and
considering that is expected to be
approximately 15
per person per
month so we're looking at a very
significant increase just in
prescription writing or in in filling
the prescriptions for an oral
fluoride uh again the the department
provides support for the school and
Community Based Dental Programs that
provide prevention and treatment for
dental decay it's assumed that the
dental Department could not increase
funding to these areas who when the
fluoride is ceased um from adding to the
water due to funding uh constraints so a
situation where it is anticipated that
there will be somewhere between 1 and $3
million in additional expenses if the
floration is
removed all I have any questions for
either of our
speakers representative
Donnelly then representative Darby thank
you chair um thank you for taking my
question you mentioned that um all
products all bottled waters all things
that we drink contain fluoride in that
and I was just reading online that that
they came back and it said that wasn't
necessarily true do you have any
evidence of that um and can you provide
backup to that yeah sorry if I said all
um products are fluoridated that was not
my intention many bottled waters are
fluoridated and the division of Public
Health actually tests bottled water for
you know different concentrations and
then again if you if something's
manufactured using water that's
floridated it is then
floridated thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question on related note
um
for um going back to that uh lawsuit
that's been U discussed a couple of
times um does as far as you know does
that only apply to community water
systems and not um bottled water that
would be
fluoridated yeah so fluoride is an
interesting just thing in general
because it's regulated by by two
different agencies depending on where
it's being used so FDA regulates bottled
water because that's food and then EPA
regulates the community water
fluoridation system so it's and they
have different standards of how they
assess um and make decisions EPA does
not assess for health benefit they focus
on health risk and FDA balances
both do we have any other questions
uh I just have one if I might just for
the record I've read quickly your
testimony normally I see a spec
specification are you opposed are you in
favor or do you take no position as the
department on the bill I just wanted to
get it on record yeah we're providing
we're here to provide information and to
just Express serious concerns about the
impact on oral health and cost thank you
well thank you both appreciate that uh
next up New Hampshire Dees Brandon Karan
and Karen I can't read your last name
creeper thank
you and they have written testimony and
they're the last pink card I
had well the testimon is being passed
out if you don't mind me just ask asking
is there anyone else that wants to fill
out a pin
card so I'll know if I get any coming I
don't see any more thank you Mr Karen
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I'm Brandon kernin I'm the
administrator of the drinking water and
groundwater Bureau I'm here with Karen
Craver who's the administrator of the
environmental health program at Dees and
we're really here to provide some
background information and answer
questions we're not taking a specific
position on the bill today I think as
you've heard currently state law has a
very good process for communities to put
in fluoridation or to abolish it um this
bill would dismantle that process and
prohibit fluoridation
Statewide I want to just point out from
our standpoint of Department we're aware
of the optimal recommendations for
florid drinking water to for its great
benefit for oral health um to be at a
concentration of7 milligrams per liter
and we have rules and procedures in
place to ensure water systems are
monitoring that daily and then providing
information to the state so that we have
oversight to ensure that that system of
putting fluoridation in the water is is
hitting those optimal levels and so it's
a very good process to to support the
fluoridation um efforts in the State uh
we do regulate fluoride for 1500 Public
Water Systems there are 2500 there's
three categories there's are Community
Water Systems um which is like city of
Manchester Port Smith or it could be uh
a Condominium Association where people
live essentially and and get their water
they have to regularly test their water
for fluoride um there's non Community
non-transient Water Systems that's a
place like a school or a place of work
where the same people go to the same
place and drink the same water on a
regular basis they have to test for
fluoride on a regular basis and then
there's the what we call the transient
water system so that's about a thousand
water systems and that might be like a
fast food place where different people
drinking the water every day and they do
not have to test off for f because
that's it's a chronic exposure concern
and so the regulations don't apply to
those systems and I'm happy to say that
all the all the systems that do have to
test for Florida and state comply with
the drinking water standards of four
milligrams per liter they're below that
at this point we don't have a lot of
systems that exceed that but there is
sort of a belt in the Tamworth Bartle
Conway area where there's a number of
very small community water systems that
have exceedances and have to put in
treatment um which can be somewhat
complicated for fluide but they're doing
that
successfully I just want to point out
that as an agency we constantly are
tracking the best science around all
contaminants and looking for
peer-reviewed consensus information and
we continue to do that we are very much
aware of the EPA Court ruling which
really just tells EPA to go back and
assess risk there's a lot of lot of on
Liners in that that finding including
that this ruling doesn't really find
that fluid has been injured to Public
Health but it does say it needs EPA
needs to look at risk and potentially
regulate or respond to that risk and so
that's not a terrible thing to ask
someone to look at the science again and
Report out and so no matter if the
rulings appealed or not it doesn't
immediately affect us because it's what
we would want EPA to do to be looking at
the best science and and updating any
assessments and I don't know if you
anything you want to add no I think
Brendan pretty much covered it um you
know I mean at the federal level and
then ALS so at the state level I'm here
representing I'm here representing the
state level the environmental health
program but we are tasked with risk
assessors and toxicologists and there is
a process for assessing risk of
chemicals um like fluoride and in in
that risk assessment process we are
tasked with considering the most
vulnerable population to select a level
that's protective of the most vulnerable
population so as Brandon noted the the
maximum contaminant level for
fluoridation or for fluoride is is 4
milligrams per L secondary Max
contaminant of 2 milligrams per liter
and that's where that notification
occurs and the optimization level is far
below that at
point7 thank you any questions for these
speakers representative Ryan then
representative ghou thank you for Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question if a community receives
fluoride in their water now and they
decide to have a vote to not receive
fluide anymore is there a process in
place to stop that from happening for
them
yes the statute has a process for either
putting in fluoridation or abolishing it
it's kind of the same process it depends
if you're a a village District um a town
or a city the number of signatures for a
petition to get it on the ballot and
then there's a vote and so you can
abolish it the same way it's put in it's
only allowed to be reconsidered once
every three years um so it can't be done
over and over again but that there is a
standing process to abolish
it representative goule
okay in your testimony here um excuse
me um you have a sentence uh on the
second page due to naturally occurring
fluoride this means that systems that
practice Community water
fluoridation may have lower levels of
fluoride in the drinking water than
systems that do not actively practice
fluoridation could you explain that a
little bit more
yes so for a system that's adding
fluoride they would have 7 milligrams
per liter fluoride and that's carefully
monitored daily by certified operators
but then within the state we have
naturally occurring fluoride mostly in
Bedrock again mostly not entirely but
mostly in that Bartlett Tamworth Conway
area and fluoride in those Wells could
be over two could be over four if
they're over four they have to implement
treatment or corrective action and and
we have a few that do that so that one
ones that aren't adding fluoride might
have it just from the the geology
they're drawing their water
from thank
you followup are you all set I guess
representative is all set representative
NAB thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um there was a
comment made earlier about the different
types of compounds added or different
variations of fluoride added and you
list some of them in this chart can you
speak to the difference between one of
them and a naturally occurring
they're just forms of fluoride that have
been processed to be very pure and food
grade and combined so that they mix with
water very effectively and so you you
just wouldn't want to take plain
fluoride and plop it in water it
wouldn't dissolve appropriately so it's
a it's a way that you can dose at these
very low levels consistently and
effectively and again although all
compounds come from somewhere a lot of
things including medicine um come from
odd places but they're highly processed
and become highly pure before they're
used for food additives or drinking
water additives thank you and it's all
regulated by NSF and certified that
way yeah I would be surprised
representative Darby representative
Darby go ahead I was watching but I've
been very quiet today you've been very
good today thank you so much for taking
my question um I I think I heard that
you said that um uh you you consider the
health risks to the most vulnerable
populations and so you know um we we saw
earlier that there's a statement that
has to go out on um as part of some RSA
that says um not to give uh um bottle or
sorry water that's been treated um to
infants um in if they drink a lot of uh
formula or something like that so I
would assume that that means that they
this was the this was in one of the
handouts we received I think maybe you
heard the testimony on it um so that
mean makes me think that probably under
six months is one of these most
vulnerable populations and can you talk
about about um the risk of um you know s
um parts per million um to that uh you
know that infant
population so I can try to answer this
but I'll preface it by saying that I'm
not a toxicologist and I'm not a risk
assessor I'm the administrator of the
environmental health program and so I
have a team and I'm happy to bring those
question back to them but um I think
generally speaking when we're setting
health or making health-based
recommendations for environmental
quality standards pregnant women and
young children and infants are are those
vulnerable populations that we consider
um and my point in raising that before
was to say that the the actual um
standard that has been set for floride
is much higher than the point s um it's
it's four parts per million where you
where you might expect to see um
negative Health impacts two parts per
million where you see um like cosmetic
cosmetic impacts and then point seven
where we would see a health
benefit follow up okay thank you very
much for that thank you Mr chair thank
you very much for that so just you know
just being explicit here um you have
some Public Health uh some public water
supply that tests set you know three um
uh five times at 3.7 uh parts per
million you're um and that's going in uh
for example um formula and um you know
mothers that are breastfeeding are you
know drinking that water as well but
there's no uh there's no requirement
necessary to say hey you're at 3.5 parts
per million is that
true there's notifications when it's
over two parts per million that that
there's risk for fosis um at that point
I say
that's correct I I will say everyone is
provided a summary of their water
quality data through the consumer
confidence report each year so they
would know they have fluoride in there
and could and could assess that or call
us if they have specific questions that
data is mandated to be provided to the
public thank you any other questions for
our
speakers Sergeant thank you Mr chair um
do you think we should wait for the EPA
to do its job and let us know the
results before we do anything on the
floride law in New
Hampshire so the department doesn't take
a position on the bill today but we
continue to look at the science and
continue to support rules that have 7
milligrams per liter and as I spoke
earlier the court order directed APA to
look at risk and in fact a few years ago
when EPA asked the states what do you
want us to look at we named FL magines
and other compounds is something that
warrants updated risk assessments so we
think it's a really good idea to always
be looking at the best science and
updating recommendations we always would
support
that any other
questions I don't see any thank you both
for your presentation uh is there anyone
else that wants to speak on this bill
I'll ask one more time anyone else that
wants to speak on this bill so I'll
close the hearing on this bill and for
those Pres in the
um
resources uh
let's 691 going to sub committe we
haven't decided
yet our presenter is in a hurry to get
an answer so uh in order to preface
where he wonders where are we going
we're going to take a 20 minute break so
you can go into caucus and we're going
to come back at 4:10
410 and I forgot to ask representative
Sergeant for the blue sheets in the
online thank you Mr chairman online 102
support 364 opposed on the blue sheets
eight support seven opposed thank you
very much and we'll see everybody back
at uh 410 thank
you
e
e e
forgetting to turn it
on good afternoon I'm going to open the
um voting on the bills that we heard
heard uh late morning and early
afternoon we have three bills so to
exact first I open the exacting on HB
663 and I believe representative
Sergeant you have a motion uh thank you
Mr chair yes I'd like to move that house
pill 663 be ought to pass do want have a
second yes Mr chair second so I have a
first and a second would the maker wish
to speak uh yes Mr chairman thank you
the division of historical resources of
the Department of Natural and cultural
resources has asked for the ability to
expend uh moose plate money uh partially
on uh administrative costs of overseeing
the Moose plate program and the AG's
office has already said they have that
Authority but that uh has the AG's
office has also requested that DHR uh
seek clarification uh which this law
accomplishes and I support it for that
reason thank you is a second wish to
speak seconds okay any other discussion
on that if not I'd ask the clerk to read
the
roles HB
663 ought to pass representative Davis
yes representative G yes representative
Donnelly yes clerk wrote yes
representative Bridle yes representative
Muffet yes representative Lenny yes
representative Taylor yes representative
neb yes representative ale yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
Ryan Yes representative Sergeant
yes and the chair
yes 1 15 1 15 o
consent thank you next I'll open the
exact hearing on HB
683 relative to off Highway recreational
vehicles I believe attorney Veil you
have a motion
yes I do Mr chair not sure how to take
that
um is that a good thing it is
a uh I'd like to make a motion of itl on
um inexpedient to legislate on relative
to off-highway recreational vehicles HB
683 and representative Baldwin I would
like so we have a motion made and
seconded to itl with the maker like to
speak yes Mr chair thank you and just
I'll be very brief there were two major
issues with the bill one opening up
counties to um a process that they would
want to anticipate and another thing
about the notification of a Butter's
changing hands and really where the
liability lies and um we did hear
significant testimony today and over the
course of the last few weeks about the
importance of bringing all of these
measures before the house B 1188
commission that is formed to here the
matters related to abutters and ohvs and
highways and involves everybody that
should be there to make these decisions
so for that reason I oppose the bill and
um thank you thank you anyone else we
wish to speak on
this hearing none seeing none I'll ask
the clerk to read the roles on H H
b683 HB 6883 itl representative Davis
no representative G yes representative
Donnelly yes clerk roach yes
representative Bridal yes representative
Muffet yes representative lny yes
representative Taylor yes representative
neb yes representative
Vale yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
Ryan Yes representative Sergeant yes and
the chair
yes 141
consent without objection no objection
okay thank you last I'll call the exact
on our last bill um HB 691 prohibiting
the addition of fluidization chemicals
to Public Water Systems uh
representative Bridal you have a motion
yes uh thank you Mr chair I motion to
itl HB 691 representative Donell I
second it so we have a motion made and
seconded would you like to speak to your
motion yes I would thank you Mr chair uh
for um this bill I believe it's a matter
of uh local control uh all these
communities have the ability to opt into
uh Florida the water uh they also have
the ability to opt out um I think that
is the essence of this bill and that's
why I support uh itl thank you does a
second wish to speak no we've heard
plenty today thank you thank you anyone
else wish to speak on
691 don't see anyone so I'll ask the
clerk to read the role HB 691 itl
representative Davis yes representative
G yes representative Donnelly yes clerk
root yes representative Bridal yes
representative muffett yes
representative Lenny yes representative
Taylor yes representative NAB yes
representative Vil
no representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
Ryan Yes representative Sergeant yes and
the chair
yes
141 any objection to
consent so we'll put that on consent and
that ends all of our hearings and
executing today and I thank everybody
for their cooperation testimony and
patience and we'll see everyone tomorrow
in session and right now we're not
scheduled to meet next week we've
finished our 21 bills I just need the
reports so get them in as soon as you
can thank you thank you very much